with us on the crucial question of
accountability i have the honor to
welcome the u.n high commissioner for
human rights michelle bachelet icc
prosecutor karim khan prosecutor general
of ukraine irina
and civil society representatives miss
amal clooney from clooney foundation for
justice and miss ida sawyer director of
crisis and conflict division at human
rights watch reporting from the ground
with us here today is also the executive
director of human rights watch mr
kenneth roth and without further ado i'd
like to invite high commissioner
bachelet who is joining us from geneva
via vct for her briefing dear michelle
you have the floor
thank you very much
excellencies colleagues i'm grateful to
albania and france for organizing
today's cruise crucial and timely
discussion
in the words of a woman from european on
the 15th of april after her house burned
down i will quote her
i'm sad about our house in which i was
born and i have lived during my whole
life but i am even more sad that the
whole history of my family
burned down
accountability is a cornerstone of
upholding human rights
yet two months into the russian armed
attack on ukraine we ask who will be
held accountable
when and how
as i stated to the human rights council
in march the gross violations of
international human rights law
and serious violations of humanitarian
law that have occurred in particular
regarding the principle of this
distinction and the prohibition of in
indiscriminate attacks may amount to war
crimes
the victims of these violations and
their families need reparation they need
to obtain effective remedies for the
harm and tragedies they have endured and
efforts aimed at regressing violations
must begin now
this sends a clear message that
violations of international law will not
go and address that individuals will be
held to account
and the parties to the conflict will be
held responsible for internationally
wrong acts their forces commit for this
to happen there are at least four
critical steps
first
a comprehensive preservation of all
types of evidence related to alleged
international humanitarian human
wrestling violations including digital
evidence second
decent treatment of all mortal remains
including their proper
identification and bureau as well as
forensic examinations of bodies to
establish cause of death
third the effective and comprehensive
recording of all deaths linked to the
conflict including civilian casualties
and finally the development of
comprehensive policy mechanism to
provide remedy and reparations for the
victims of serious violations of
international law related to the armed
conflict since the 24th february 2022 as
well as those who suffered harm before
since april 2014
this includes families of those killed
and those injured
individual criminal responsibility for
war crimes that may have been committed
in ukraine will have to be determined by
a fair trial before a court or tribunal
in full compliance with international
rule of law standards this is the
primary duty of the parties to the
conflict
as the work continues and intensifies so
to thus the magnitude of human suffering
we are gravely concerned by the racing
civilian death toll mass displacement
and the destruction of civilians
objected after today my office has
documented and verified
5939 civilian casualties with
2787 kill and
317 52 injured but actual figures are
considerably higher and my office is
working to estimate them
most of these have been caused by the
use of explosive weapons with wide area
effects in populated areas such as
shelling from heavy artillery and
missile and air strikes
the staggering scale of human rights
violation in bookshop has shocked
ukraine and the world during a one day
visitor team documented the unlawful
killing including summary executions of
50 civilians mostly men but also women
and children
continue to follow up all reports of
violations in bhuja as well as other 300
other allegations of killings including
summary executions of civilians in more
than 30 settlements in kiev chevy heath
her hip and swimming regions controlled
by russian armed forces in late february
and march
ochr has corroborated over 170 cases of
apparent arbitrary detention and
enforced disappearances of public
officials journalists and activists in
areas controlled by russian armed forces
ohsr has also received information about
alleged arbitrary and incoming type in
communicable detention by upending
forces of people aligned with them
my office is also looking into dozens of
allegations of conflict-related sexual
violence
the treatment of prisoners of war by the
parties also raises serious concerns
videos apparently recorded by combatants
are available online
depicting intimidation torture and even
killing of prisoners of war
accountability for these violations and
the rights of victims to a remedy and
reparations must be ensured
excellencies calling my office is
committed to engaging with all actors
working towards accountability within
our respective frameworks and mandates
here i welcome the establishment of the
independent international commission of
inquiry on ukraine which is an important
step and i emphasize that all efforts
should be coordinated with victims
rights including protection at the
center of the approaches
yet looking at what is playing out today
will be in vain if we can commit to
preventing future violations and
atrocities
our efforts for peace must be sustained
and unwavering
in the meanwhile the parties to the
conflict must urgently reassess the
method used to conduct hostilities the
use of weapons with wide area effects in
populated areas
ceased immediately
summary executions other unlawful
killings and enforced disappearances
must come to an end now
my office will continue crucial work of
documenting violations of international
human rights law and international
humanitarian law
to guarantee our monitoring is
independent and impartial our human
rights officers must have complete and
unemployed impeded access to all
affected areas in ukraine as well as
access to information
this futile and senseless war has
already caused immeasurable human
validity let us commit to putting a stop
to it before we have more death more
suffering and more perpetrators to hold
to account i thank you manager
i thank the high commissioner for her
insightful briefing
that sheds light on the horrible
suffering afflicted upon civilians i'd
like to highlight the fact that the
office of the high commissioner uses a
strict assessment methodology and on
that basis it has demonstrated that
russian armed forces have
indiscriminately shelled and bombed
populated areas killing civilians and
wrecking hospitals schools and other
civilian infrastructure actions that may
amount to war crimes
i now would like to give the floor to
the chief icc prosecutor karim khan
to provide his insights on the matter
may i remind everyone that early this
month prosecutor khan visited the towns
of bucha and borodyanka where there are
reasonable grounds to believe that
crimes that fall within the jurisdiction
of the icc have been committed
the floor is yours prosecutor
excellencies
firstly i'd like to start by thanking
the public missions of albania and the
republic of france uh for convening this
session and it's a real
uh honor albeit in
desperately sad circumstances to share
uh this platform with other with the
very distinguished panelists
and all of the um
ambassadors and ministers in the room
today
we are by any metric
in a time of massive uncertainty
massive uncertainty for the people of
ukraine
uh massive uncertainty for the people
in the region
and i think it's not uh hyperbole to say
the world is holding his breath
what direction are we going in
are we heading towards peace
or more violence more tears and more
suffering
it is a moment the events particularly
since the 24th of february i think
um some have thought well what's the
point of international law what's the
point of the international criminal
court what's the point of all these
conventions
all these conferences that many in this
room have attended and taken part in the
wonderful drafting the high lofty ideals
of the preambles what's the point of it
all when people
are suffering in so many parts of the
world
and yet in that moment of otherwise
despair
i think something
unique is happening
it is a dawning realization that the
rule of law is not a passive spectator
but it's an intrinsic
um
part
an intrinsic buckle
to keep us together
43 states
have referred the situation
in ukraine
to the international criminal court
and that's the first time such a number
have done such a thing
and i think it is really important to
realize
and i think we're seeing it the the
young
green springs of hope
in the wasteland that we otherwise
survey
that
the law
is more relevant now than ever
not only to stop us drifting further
apart
but to prevent us colliding with more
brutality against one another
i've stated repeatedly
since my first statement when i was in
cox's bazar
on the 25th
of february
that the law applies equally to all
sides
all parties to the conflict whether
ukraine or the russian federation
whether they're state actors or
non-state actors
have certain clear obligations
we've heard from the high commission of
human rights about the principles of
proportionality the principles of
distinction
the types of weapons munitions and
events that are
in the public space of discussion
but this is nothing new
this has been known since nuremberg
this has been known for a long time
the issue is not a misunderstanding or
confusion about the law
it is a
greater well
acute realization
that the law has to be applied
if we are to continue
going forward as a species
as communities as civilization and our
states
um i i do take uh
the the opportunity
to really um call but both to uh thank
or appreciate
um ukraine's
declaration under 12 3 of the rome
statute because that's the only reason
we have jurisdiction
and also to
call upon ukraine with all due dispatch
to pass the necessary corporation law so
that the obligations that arose and uh
12-3 declaration can be properly
implemented
at the same time
and i've said it before but i think it's
really important to emphasize in this
forum
and i acknowledge also the
representative of the russian federation
i'm pleased the russian federation is in
this room
along with the government of ukraine and
so many others
but this is a time when we need to
mobilize the law
and send it into battle
not to uh not on the side of ukraine
against the russian federation on the
side of the russian federation against
ukraine but on the side of humanity to
protect
to preserve
to shield people who are children
who are women and who are men who have
certain basic rights and at that age at
those
whether they are russian or whether
they're ukrainian is absolutely relevant
their families and their lives are being
torn apart
so if this moment is not a moment for us
to define and strain our sinews and come
together what moment will we wait for
and will we be alive to see it
you know
when we look at
the parties to the conflict in ukraine
when we look at
the russian federation and ukraine
i think
bad though things are we should pause
and look back
you know as a young child we all taught
history and we love to study it
and one is absolutely staggered
by the tremendous suffering
that the people of the ussr
in today's russia and today's ukraine
suffered
at the hands of national socialism
millions upon millions
and in the midst of that particularly
bleak catastrophe
we saw perhaps unparalleled
heroism
and courage
it was in 1943
in the city of kharkiv
that 30 000
people were killed and seek scrutiny we
don't want to be sold a dad we want to
get to the bottom of matters
but at the same time nobody can be a
spectator
the day before yesterday
i did something that has not been done
in the life of the icc before
and life of the office that i now lead
i signed an agreement
to join a jet a joint investigation team
with ukraine with poland and with
lithuania
there are nine other structural
investigations
uh underway
and i'm really pleased that the
prosecutor general of ukraine arena
vendikova will be speaking today and we
have other high-level representatives
and i look forward to
working together
i've been
to ukraine twice tel aviv and to kiev
i've been to bucha and borodienko the
team have been more widely forensic
scientists lawyers and investigations
and we will keep on partnering with
anybody
but subjecting it whatever you receive
as i've said
to impartial analysis
i've sent three communications
to the russian federation
i have not received a reply
but i will keep on trying
because i want to say very clearly and i
hope it is relayed
however welcome or otherwise messages
may be i think we have a duty to convey
messages
that my office and myself have no agenda
no political agenda
other than to get to the truth
and to the extent
there is fake news
to the extent there is
collusion or there are attempts to
deceive the world
what better way
to expose a lie
than subjected to independent
investigations and analysis
so my door is open
i will also keep knocking on the door
and i hope for the sake of our own
responsibilities to
for the sake of our international legal
obligations
for the sake of humanity at large in the
principles of the un charter
in whose building we sit
we work with more deliberation more
sincerity more effectiveness and try to
build trust because trust can be built
even in a battlefield
we see on tv screens and i've spoken to
victims and survivors
a pictures that are not vague i've seen
refugees largely women and
children
this caravan of people
with their plastic bags and their bags
crossing on foot into poland
i've seen individuals in borijenko
completely non-scripted walking around
without any supervision
surrounded sitting around a blackened
kettle
in very very cold temperatures
because that's their current existence
at the moment and of course i've seen uh
body bags and other
evidence of killings and we need to find
out
how did people die and who did it and
then insist
on accountability
but people
have lost everything
people have fled with nothing
so are we to
be so self-indulgent as an international
community
to talk politics
when people
are scared and children are shivering on
all sides
and it doesn't matter if a child is in
the
russian controlled area or if a child is
in the ukrainian controlled area or for
women
we should view them as our children
we should view them as our family and
unless we have these basic principles
permeating our spirit
i really think it is a terrible tragedy
that of course the law is there because
certain issues are not just of morality
they incur legal responsibility
i think in short it's not an
overstatement to say that this is a
singular moment
it's a critical juncture
the implications as i said at the outset
are profound in ukraine but they extend
beyond ukraine
it's a time
to cling
to the law
it is a time to uphold the law
if we don't cling
with the greatest of respect
to the law in this moment
we will be left with nothing to cling to
accept despair
accept suffering
and individually
we cannot allow that to happen
collectively we must not
rest until it stops
and that sanity and justice prevails on
all sides thank you so much
[Music]
thank you wholeheartedly prosecutor khan
for the detailed and chilling account
i would like to take the opportunity to
appeal to member states to continue
supporting the independent work of the
icc prosecutor
which is vital for strengthening
accountability for crimes of aggression
and crimes against humanity
further on the establishment by the
human rights commission of inquiry on
ukraine in early march
is a milestone in the swift response of
the international community to ensure
accountability by using all legal
instruments available the mandate of the
commission is to investigate all alleged
violations and abuses of human rights
and violations of international
humanitarian law and related crimes in
the context of the aggression against
ukraine by the russian federation to
establish the facts circumstances and
the causes of any such violations and
abuses i am pleased to give the floor to
the chair of the commission of inquiry
on ukraine mr eric mose you have the
floor
thank you very much madam chair
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of the independent
international commission of inquiry on
ukraine
i would like to thank the organizers the
permanent missions to
the u.n of the republic of albania and
of france for having invited the
commission to this ideal meeting
this is the first time the commission
appears in the public context
the three commissioners are all present
mrs jasmine zumhoud and i are peace are
participating remotely
and mr pablo de grave is physically
present
at your meeting in new york
limited time has passed since the
president of the human rights council
appointed the members of the commission
on 30th march this year
recruitment of our staff is ongoing and
the office of the secretariat in vienna
is under establishment
given this very early stage of the
commission's existence
the three members have considered
carefully whether we should participate
today
we have decided to do so demonstrating
in a visible way the commission's
availability to communicate with all
stakeholders
from the beginning
we consider it important to follow
discussions of relevance to the
commission's work
today's topic accountability for
atrocities is an important element of
the commission's mandate
ensuring accountability is of course
only possible with reliable and
sufficient evidence
resolution 49 1 contains several
references to the significance of this
the commission shall investigate all
alleged violations and abuses of human
rights a violation of international
humanitarian law related crimes
it shall establish the facts of any
such violations and abuses
it shall
collect consolidate and analyze such
evidence
and systematically record and preserve
all the information documentation and
evidence
in performing this huge task the
commission will build on the work of the
u.n human rights monetary mission in
ukraine
and work in close cooperation with that
mission and with the office of the high
commissioner for human rights as
mandated by our resolution
the commission will discuss the
implementation of these provisions with
the high commissioner's office
including during our physical meeting in
geneva in a couple of weeks
we considered this element of our
mandate to be important particularly
given the monetary missions extensive
experience in ukraine
it's a well-known fact that a large
number of entities are investigating the
situation in ukraine
both international and national bodies
as mentioned in the organizers concept
note for this idea meeting there is
reason to believe that coordination can
ensure
the efficiency of investigations
and we intend to look into this issue
turning specifically to the ongoing icc
investigation i was very pleased to note
the presence of the prosecutor mr khan
at this meeting
our commission will establish contact
with the icc in the near future
more generally the commission will seek
contact with the parties to the conflict
with victims
civil societies
member states and other stakeholders
the main purpose is to obtain
information of relevance to the mandate
it will be necessary to build upon a
broad range of sources which will have
to be assessed together
the commission aims to visit ukraine and
other areas where information and
evidence is available
the commission's broad mandate include
all kinds of allegations irrespective of
whether they receive extensive press
coverage or less attention
in conformity with this mandate the
commission will seek to contribute to
accountability
while not a strictly traditional
instance one of its tasks is to identify
where possible
individuals and entities responsible for
violation or abuses of human rights of
international humanitarian law other
related crimes
but let me stress that when informing
its task the commission is as stated in
the mandate independent it has no link
to any particular country party or
entity
the commission will submit its reports
to the un human vice council and to the
general assembly and its conclusions
will be based on the independent
assessment of the commissioners and
their analysis of the information and
evidence that comes out of the
investigations
the commission is of course
fully aware of the challenges in
executing its mandate under the current
circumstances
but also of its importance especially
when they are conflicting versions of
the facts or even disinformation
in conformity with established
principles the commission will assess
the evidence carefully giving particular
way to primary evidence and seeking
corroboration whenever needed
over the years the many commissions of
inquiry established by the human rights
council have built up a considerable
experience in this field
as already mentioned the commission
finds itself at an early stage of its
work so this is not the time to give
long statements
but i would like to thank the high
commissioner for human rights mrs
barceley for having set up an excellent
startup team which has been of great
assistance
and let me end by reiterating that the
commission is ready to communicate with
anyone who may assist it in the
completion of its mandate thank you
madam chair
i thank mr mose for his valuable remarks
and we look forward to the report of the
three independent members of the
commission of inquiry on ukraine now i'd
like to give the floor to the prosecutor
general of ukraine irina benedictova may
i recall that miss veritova is visiting
the terrain every day and has already
opened over 8 thousand criminal
investigations related to the war and
has identified over 500 suspects miss
verdictova you have the floor
excellencies ladies and gentlemen i
would like to think permanent missions
of albania and france and other
sponsoring states for this opportunity
to talk with you about the outstanding
issue of accountability for
international crimes committed by russia
in ukraine
as a prosecutor general it is my direct
responsibility to document and process
crimes committed and ensure
the appropriate and timely prosecution
and of course accountability for crimes
starts with evidence
however before i proceed with giving you
insights about our efforts in this
direction i will take few moments to
inform you what ukrainian prosecutors
are facing on the ground
violations committed by the russian
federation in ukraine are colossal and
in their scale and nature
as madame bachelet assembled recently
international humanitarian law has not
merely been ignored
but seemingly tossed aside
russia's actions amount to crimes
against humanity and war crimes we also
believe that there is a reasonable basis
to argue that the pattern of violations
acutely resembles the crime of genocide
russian forces disregard principles and
norms
applicable to international armed
conflicts
from early days
russians armed forces indiscriminately
shelled and bombed populated areas
targeting civilians and civilian objects
such as hospitals schools and other
civilian infrastructure
just dry numbers
according to available data and this
excludes information from areas like
mariupol
where we do not have an access
over
4300 civilians objects were targeted and
majority of them destroyed
including
275 schools
near um if i
even i can give you correct number
169 kindergartens over
340 medical facilities and more than 500
are the civilian infrastructure objects
withdrawal of russian forces from the
key region yielded insight into the
scale of atrocities
we have all seen brutal footage from key
region towns of bucha european
baradyanka hostile and others with
bodies with bound hands and clear signs
of torture
and mutilation aligning the streets
bodies of women's and children
raped and potentially burned
that lay on cold concrete
or a tertiary chamber in butcher where
russian forces tortured peaceful
civilians and shot them afterwards
what could be scarier than a torture
chamber in 21st century in the vicinity
of the capital of european country
we document some executions of civilians
and freshly dug mass graves with
hundreds of bodies in there
evidence strongly suggests that
civilians were internationally traded
in widespread and systematic matter
sorry mana typical of atrocity crimes
this is a common picture in all areas
direct attacks against civilians is a
tactic of intimidation and punishment
since russia did not manage to achieve
its military and policy objective of
subjecting ukraine and ukrainians
just to bring one example evacuation of
civilian population from maroon
is very difficult
when we were planning evacuation routes
russian side
requested the location of buses where
which vacation would be held
however once this information was
received
they fired at them from providers and
grants until there was nothing to
evacuate
this is the methods of warfare that
russian army is using
about 130 000 civilians included women
children and elderly many of them
wounded after merciless attacks and
bombardments
are currently in marupa blocked and
beginning to for riskier
we also observe a very some practice
for possible transfer population and
especially children that found
themselves in the hands of occupancy to
russia
this is another clear violation of
international humanitarian law that need
to be urgently addressed
to date
near 4 000 civilians were killed
including
217 children and 371 women again this
number covers only areas under ukrainian
control
as clearly indicated by the recent
report of the oscu moscow mechanism it
is unconceivable that so many civilians
would have been killed and injured and
so many civilian objects damaged or
destroyed if russia had respected its
international humanitarian law
obligations in terms of distinctions
proportionality and precautions in
conducting hostilities in ukraine
let me remind you that the turning frame
of moscow mechanism report did not
include the atrocities discovered in
butcher and other towns
russia has also been using explosives
such as the cluster munitions
munitions with the large blast radius
such as the large bombs or missiles
in guided missiles artillery and mortars
multiple launch rocket systems as well
as insider weapons
white phosphorous and thermobaric bombs
also known as vacuum bombs
in decently populated areas this is
another proof that russia blatantly
disregards its obligation
anti-international humanitarian law
and how russia reacts to these
atrocities
just several days ago putin honored
64th motor uh rifle brigade who are
responsible for large-scale atrocities
in butcher with the title of guards for
defending
motherland and state interests and
prayed that mass heroism and very
tenacity and courage of its members
this is nothing else but mocking of
international law by russia
these are circumstances that we are
faced with
our objective however is clear broadest
possible collection of evidence and
documentation of every crime to ensure
accountability for perpetrators and
justice for victims
evidence gathering and investigation
amid war and access in hotspots
is a been sticking work
we have already lost some of our
colleagues in the process
however to date we have opened over
uh
8 000 investigations into instance of
violations of laws and customs of war
this number grows every day
unfortunately the volume of crimes
and accordingly the evidence that we
have to document and work with is
extremely capacious
which is a challenge for the national
investigations authority of ukraine
we however understand that main burden
of responsibility for the investigation
of crimes rests with ukraine in
accordance with our international
obligations
in this process we are assisted by
international community as well as best
international experts i would like to
underscore the efforts of media male
clooney in the format of legal task
force on accountability of crimes
committed in ukraine with an aim to
support ukraine in delivering justice
for victims of international crimes
committed by russia in our country
apart from domestic jurisdiction and
assistance from our friends
there are currently several
international efforts underway to seek
justice for war crimes crimes against
humanity and other crimes
we're actively cooperating with the
office of prosecutor of the
international criminal court
which has launched in full-fledged
investigation in the situation in
ukraine we stand ready uh to do
everything in our part to seize the
court we are grateful to prosecutor han
for his active engagement and
development of effective coordination
and for his actually brave
role and
his two visits to ukraine um give me
you know you may be
some new trust in international
humanitarian law in addition already 14
national jurisdictions beyond ukraine
have ongoing criminal proceedings
regarding international crimes taking
place in ukraine
we cooperate very closely to ensure the
maximum efficacy of such criminals
proceedings as well as
their outcomes
we have established separate joint
investigations teams which uh with the
national authorities of lithuania and
poland and support of hierarchy to
enable to exchange of information
facilitate and strengthen the capacity
of investigations into war crimes crimes
against humanity and other crimes
we are glad that recently icc team
became a part of joint investigation
team this will definitely make our
command effort more effective
we are looking forward to cooperation
with u.n commission of inquiry
established by human rights council
the rules of war applied to all those
who participate in war from soldiers on
the ground to the commander-in-chief
while as previously note will of justice
for international crimes turn slowly
they do so
yelled in concrete results especially in
the circumstances of vocal and
resounding support of international
community
we will use every channel
and a venue to enforce accountability
for those who are orchestrated and
enabled commission of crimes and provide
measure of justice to victims
now we have an opportunity to advance
justice and accountability
faster we deliver results sooner it will
have
effect on the ground
this will send a clear signal against
similar criminal acts in the future and
most importantly will serve justice for
victims and
survivors
doing this in common responsibility on
the mankind thank you for your attention
i thank prosecutor general benedictova
for her briefing i would like to commend
her for her monumental work in the
service of justice on a personal note i
would like to also recognize her role as
the first woman prosecutor general of
ukraine
working relentlessly to collect the
stories of ukrainians and transform them
into facts and evidence before they
vanish the role of civil society is
crucial in fact finding and proof
gathering on the ground as well as in
supporting the process of information
and knowledge sharing among all actors
of accountability mechanisms it is a
pleasure for me to now give the floor to
miss amal clooney representing clooney
foundation for justice who has been
doing admirable work to advance justice
and accountability the world over dear
amal the floor is yours
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you thank you so much to the
ambassadors who invited me to address
you today
and may i also thank two of my fellow
speakers prosecutor benedictova and
prosecutor khan for the incredible work
that you are both doing
it is an honor to be working with the
ukrainian government
and for the ukrainian people
as they battle for their freedom
when the government asked me to
provide some advice on the ways to
pursue justice i felt i think as many
lawyers do not just that there might be
an opportunity to help but that that
there's actually a duty to do so
because excellencies
ukraine is today
a slaughterhouse right in the heart of
europe
putin's aggressive war
is so outrageous that even after
repeated warnings from the u.s
and russia's long criminal record
ukrainians couldn't believe that this
could happen
and i still read news headlines
not knowing quite how to process them
could it be that thousands of children
are being forcibly deported to russia
could it be that teenage girls are being
raped in the street in front of their
family and their neighbors
was a building that had the word
children on it really bombed
and are civilians today in mario paul
systematically being tortured and
starved to death
unfortunately the answer is yes
and the world has responded
141 countries voted in the u.n general
assembly to condemn russia's aggression
the un created a commission to document
crimes
the international court of justice and
the european court of human rights have
ordered russia to suspend military
operations and safeguard civilian life
43 countries as we heard from the
prosecutor have referred ukraine to the
international criminal court this is
the biggest grouping
of states to ever do that
and at least 13 countries have now
started their own war crimes
investigations
russia has been expelled from the human
rights council and from the council of
europe countries have sent weapons and
ammunition to help the ukrainian defense
companies have pulled their businesses
out of russia and a network of
governments has imposed the toughest set
of financial sanctions ever seen
on a major economy
but the un was created this building
that we in
was constructed because of a genocide in
europe and to prevent
wars of this kind
this council has heard so many speeches
with that now hollow refrain never again
but here we are
faced with evidence of the crime of
aggression
war crimes
crimes against humanity
and mounting evidence each day of the
crime
of genocide
how did we get here
i believe we got here
by ignoring justice
for so long
for too long we have watched as
perpetrators of mass human rights abuses
have murdered
tortured and raped without consequence
from darfur to myanmar
to yemen
the perpetrators commit these crimes
believing they will get away with it
and they have been right
ten years ago
i was at the kremlin
with kofi annan whose job it was
to mediate a peaceful solution to the
syria conflict now of course neither
russia nor syria wanted a peaceful
resolution they had far too much to gain
through war
so for 11 years syrians have suffered
unabating brutality
they've been forced to listen to
speeches in rooms like this
about victims deserving justice and
perpetrators paying the price
they are still waiting
and as i've watched the coverage of the
butcher massacre
it reminds me
of the hula massacre
in syria
this council met in an emergency session
to decry the killings and people thought
it would be a turning point for
accountability
it wasn't
and now the same russian general known
as the butcher who mounted a brutal
attack on civilians in aleppo is
massacring innocent families in mario
paul
what worries me as i sit here today is
that the resolute action we've seen in
the first 50 days of this war will turn
out to be the high point
instead of the starting point of the
legal and diplomatic response
that your actions
will slowly fade into a predictable
pattern
a wealth of investigations and
committees and reports but a dearth
of prosecutions
and convictions and sentences
politicians calling for justice but not
delivering it
my fear is that you will get busy
and distracted
and that each day there'll be a little
bit less coverage of the war and people
will become a little bit more numb to it
and that ukraine will end up alone in
pursuing the perpetrators of these
atrocities
we cannot let that happen
every state that professes to respect
human rights must make sure that it does
not become a safe haven for war
criminals
perpetrators should face arrest in every
port
and ukrainians should have access to the
billions of dollars they will need to
rebuild their state
so let this be a long-awaited turning
point
for the sake of ukraine and the
credibility of this institution
let us sustain and escalate the momentum
so that a better system of justice is
within reach
a canadian judge once said that it's not
what you stand for that's important but
what you stand up for
and standing up for ukraine means that
governments should be taking concrete
steps towards justice
standing up for ukraine
means that states should support the
international criminal court clearly and
unequivocally
that means the united states should drop
unprincipled objections to the court's
jurisdiction an offer along with others
the
evidence that is needed to support the
prosecutor's work
standing up for ukraine means answering
ukraine's call to ensure that those who
are responsible for the crime of
aggression who are currently beyond the
reach of the icc can also be brought to
justice before a court of law and that
evidence of this crime is collected and
preserved
standing up for ukraine means that
states should be filing interventions in
support of ukraine's cases against
russia at the international court of
justice and the european court of human
rights
standing up for ukraine means making
each of your countries a hostile
environment for war criminals this can
be done by signing up to a treaty on
crimes against humanity that has been
more than 70 years in the making that
would allow for national prosecutions of
this crime and better evidence sharing
between states
and it can be done by expanding national
laws to capture more perpetrators of
international crimes
in the uk for example there have only
been three prosecutions of international
crimes ever
the u.s has had only three cases under
their torture act and zero cases
charging war crimes crimes against
humanity or genocide
so i commend the legislation being
proposed by senator durbin and supported
by senator graham that would bolster the
ability to prosecute these cases in the
united states and i hope that others
will follow this lead
excellencies
standing up for ukraine also means that
the un general assembly should make
clear that sovereign immunity should not
prevent russian assets russian state
assets being made available to ukraine
and its people and that the assets of
all those who support this war are at
risk
standing up for ukraine means that the
united nations should establish a
compensation commission so that
ukrainians after this war can have a
chance to rebuild their lives
and standing up for ukraine means
extending a welcoming hand to its
refugees until it's safe enough for them
to go home
excellencies when president zelensky
addressed the security council he
compared
russia's soldiers to isis
well i have spent the last seven years
representing victims of isis's genocide
our great success was that this body the
u.n security council in a rare show of
unity agreed to set up an investigation
this happened the year that my children
were born and i remember very well
coming to the council to watch the vote
it was my first trip as a working mother
but my children are now almost five
and so far most of the evidence that has
been collected by the un is in storage
because there is no international court
to put isis on trial
and when survivors ask me to explain how
can this be i can only say i am ashamed
i am ashamed that there is no system of
justice to respond to mass rape and mass
slaughter
but i believe that today
we have an opportunity to change this
and that we must do
because there is no greater value that
the un could promote
than the rule of law
and it is under serious threat when
those who commit the most heinous crimes
are not held accountable for them
we often speak of what the international
community should do
to address the horrors of war but it's
not
institutions who act it's individuals
with a conscience who are determined
enough to make a difference
peace
like war must be waged it doesn't just
happen and justice too is something we
have to fight for
i'd like to end with a reflection from
the very first international case that i
worked on
as a young lawyer in the hague i was
assigned to the trial of slobodan
milosevic whose murderous campaign to
create a greater serbia is today being
compared to russia's ambitions
over ukraine
milosevic as many of you know was the
first head of state to be put on trial
in an international court
no one thought it possible that a former
president could be in the dock in the
hague facing genocide charges
but it happened
and eventually his two henchmen ratko
mladic and radovan karadic
followed him there
they are today serving life sentences
for their crimes
so sometimes
justice takes time
you may have to wait for someone to be
out of office you may have to wait
for some of their underlings to defect
you may have to wait for them to get old
or to travel
but if we remain very focused
and very resolute
justice
may yet be
within our reach
thank you
i thank miss clooney for such an
insightful contribution
and the continuous help in prosecuting
and holding to account those responsible
for war crimes
this is indeed and should be indeed a
turning point to stand up for ukraine
but to also stand up for the
international
based
order
and
restore the confidence and credibility
of the international law and of
multilateralism that has been so
severely damaged by russia's war of
choice
but also from what we have not done in
the past that
perhaps
is leading up to what we're seeing today
nearly every corner in bucha is now a
crime scene and it felt like death was
everywhere
the evidence indicates that russian
forces occupying butcher showed contempt
and disregard for civilian life and the
most fundamental principles of the laws
of war
these are quotes from the recent report
of human rights watch published on april
21st it is my pleasure to give the floor
to the executive director of human
rights watch mr kenneth roth to
introduce also our next civil society
briefer
mr roth
the microphone is yours
thank you very much minister
um my thanks to the permanent missions
of
albania and france for convening this
very important meeting today
i have the brief but pleasurable task of
introducing ida sawyer human rights
watches director of our conflict and
crisis division
ida is one of those who has been
overseeing the teams that human rights
watch has had
in ukraine
throughout the conflict
and we have been documenting and
analyzing apparent war crimes both to
aid the very important justice effort
that has been the focus today
but also to provide as close as possible
real-time information to the
international community in order to put
pressure on the parties to refrain from
atrocities and perhaps most important to
the people of ukraine and of russia so
that they are aware of crimes being
committed in their names and can put
pressure on the relevant authorities to
stop
um ida is speaking to us from kiev um
where she is involved in these
investigations and it's my pleasure to
turn the microphone over to her
thank you ken
your excellency minister
dear distinguished guests and fellow
briefers
thank you to the permanent missions of
albania and france for convening this
important meeting
today human rights watch has the
microphone but we acknowledge the
ukrainian and russian human rights
defenders who have been many years
working on the front lines documenting
violations and pressing for credible
justice
we stand in solidarity with them during
this challenging time
the violations of human rights and
international humanitarian law by
russian forces in this conflict are
grave and severe
since 2014 we have documented a litany
of apparent war crimes that runs too
long to mention here
over the past two months since russia's
full-scale invasion of ukraine
my colleagues and i have documented the
killing of civilians and damage to homes
schools and hospitals in kharkiv cherniv
mikolai and elsewhere from apparently
indiscriminate and disproportionate
attacks
in the town of bucha and other areas
that russian forces held we found
extensive evidence of summary executions
enforced disappearances torture sexual
violence and arbitrary detentions all of
which could constitute war crimes and
potentially crimes against humanity
in mariopol tens of thousands of
civilians have been trapped as their
city was turned to rubble with little to
no food water medicine heating or means
of communication and no safe way to
escape
many have apparently been forcibly
transported to russia
we urge russia to let all civilians who
wish to flee the city to areas
controlled by ukraine to be allowed to
do so safely
we ask authorities to pay special
attention to those often
disproportionately affected in conflicts
children older people and people with
disabilities
the environmental and health impacts
will also be intense and long-term
the laws of war apply to all parties to
the conflict and we welcome ukraine's
public commitment to adhere to those
norms
one concern is ukraine's treatment of
prisoners of war and we know credible
reports of abuse that should be
investigated
another is ukraine's reported use of
cluster munitions which if accurate
should immediately stop and personnel
responsible for using these weapons held
to account
in all of our research what we hear
again and again is that the victims of
these violations want justice
the pattern of abuse we are seeing in
ukraine is consistent with
well-documented grave crimes by russian
forces in other places such as syria
the lack of accountability for those
violations has regretted regrettably
opened the door for what is occurring
today
against that background we welcome the
unprecedented response by so many
governments to encourage a range of
accountability tools so that serious
crimes get punished
we note the un human rights council's
swift action to establish a commission
of inquiry government's strong support
of an international criminal court
investigation and the decision by
judicial authorities in several
countries to pursue their own criminal
investigations under the principle of
universal jurisdiction
many governments have offered ukraine
assistance to bolster its judicial
capacity
meanwhile domestic and international
civil society groups have been
vigorously documenting violations as
they occur
they would like to stress some points to
ensure that these efforts lead to
positive outcomes for accountability
both for this conflict and for others
our research has shown that fair and
effective justice is achievable with the
right combination of appropriate laws
adequate resources and expertise
institutional commitments
effective cooperation
and above all political will
fair and effective investigations and
prosecutions at the national level will
be essential to achieve broad-based
accountability
however cases involving grave crimes are
complex to investigate prosecute and
adjudicate all the more so in the midst
of an armed conflict
increased capacity and resources
will therefore be needed to effectively
address the large-scale violations being
committed
ukrainian authorities can build on
existing domestic experience through
collaboration with those in the
international community who offer
evidentiary technical and operational
support to facilitate the investigation
and prosecution of international crimes
doing so will benefit efforts to
preserve evidence and safeguard crime
scenes and could help ensure a robust
framework for victim support and witness
protection
we also join our ukrainian civil society
colleagues in calling on ukraine to
ratify their own statute which will
allow ukraine to exercise full rights of
membership to the assembly of states
parties the icc's governing body
in addition to ratification we urge
ukraine to fully align its national
legislation with the rome statute
international law
a bill adopted by ukraine's parliament
in may 2021 that could help authorities
prosecute serious crimes domestically
has yet to be signed into law
to ensure accountability for serious
crimes in ukraine a multi-tiered
cross-cutting approach will be needed
which includes a range of actors at the
international level
the icc national courts and various
documentation efforts
we urge international actors involved in
these efforts to focus on five key
priorities
first and as many have underlined it is
imperative to ensure coordination among
the different accountability actors with
an overarching strategy
this includes common standards for the
collection preservation and archiving of
evidence
second impartial investigations and
prosecutions are essential
at stake is keeping justice above
politics for this conflict and beyond
third the international community should
ensure that justice is not sidelined in
any peace negotiations and that
compromise on justice is rejected
experience shows that decisions to
forego accountability can prove costly
in the long term
fourth authorities should work with
civil society to inform judicial
processes
beyond documentation work civil society
can facilitate access to information and
outreach to victims and affected
communities
lastly we hope that the international
community will use this moment to
strengthen the cause of justice
worldwide
we welcome the commitment to
accountability for crimes in ukraine and
would like to see this principled
support
replicated in other conflicts where
civilians suffer
such as in yemen ethiopia and palestine
to do otherwise would undermine the
international justice system as a whole
thank you for this invitation and your
attention
i thank director sawyer for her striking
account let me express once again my
appreciation for the heroic work that
human rights watch and other civil
society organizations are doing to
document these crimes to raise awareness
about them and support the alignment of
national legislation with international
law necessary to build the legal
framework for an effective domestic
investigation and prosecution of
international crimes
i would now like the opportunity to make
some brief remarks in the national
capacity as the minister for europe and
foreign affairs of albania
let me once again
thank
all of our briefers for the information
that they shared with us
it is painful it is very painful to hear
but it is important that the whole world
hears what is happening in ukraine
not just from politicians or individual
countries but from voices of authority
on the issue of human rights
from voices that people all over the
world know and accept and value as
voices that speak the truth in defense
of human rights
and in the cause for peace and justice
it is for this reason that i'm very
grateful to the high commissioner for
human rights for her brief it is for
this reason that i'm very grateful to
the icc prosecutor khan as well as i'm
so grateful from the hearts to miss amal
clooney and miss ida sawyer for their
contributions to this session
but let me also give a very special
thanks to the prosecutor general of
ukraine for her heroic work under
extraordinarily difficult conditions by
opening cases and documenting more than
8 000 cases of crimes committed by the
russian army during its illegal war of
aggression against ukraine
i come from the western balkans
a region that's until february 24th of
2022
had the distinction of having been the
theater of the last war in europe
the sins of bloodshed and of destruction
we see coming from ukraine hit home very
differently from someone
for someone for whom war and war crimes
are not things that you read about in
history books but our memories
from about a few decades ago
in 1999
my country sheltered 500 000 kosovars
fleeing the brutal war and campaigns of
ethnic cleansing
the single most vivid memory i have from
the time is of the sense of
powerlessness
to stop what was happening and the
conviction the almost violent conviction
that we all felt
that whoever was uh that whoever was uh
committing those horrible crimes had to
pay had to be held accountable
it stayed with me
and it's a walk again in me and in many
many people in albania and all over the
world when the terrible images started
coming out of ukraine this terrible
feeling of pain and rage that such
horrible crimes were being committed
right before our eyes against innocent
people in a country that had done
nothing to provoke the attack against it
it is of course not just because of the
western balkans recent history that
albania became one of the 43 countries
that referred the situation in ukraine
to the prosecutor general of the icc
just a few days after the beginning of
the conflict and it is not just because
of the painful memories of the 1990s
that albania became one of the founders
of the group of friends for
accountability we did it because we
believe that the world has an obligation
to do its best to offer justice to the
ukrainian people we did it because
despite the painful repetitions of such
tragic situations in our recent history
the world still does not have
a better more effective way to ensure
that such crimes do not happen again
except for accountability
but there is another reason why we did
it which is especially poignant in the
case of russia's illegal war of
aggression against ukraine because
russia is a permanent member of the u.n
security council a country that is
supposed to be one of the guardians of
the international rules-based system and
is therefore endowed with veto power but
has suddenly gone vogue
a supposed guardian of the system has
embarked on a war of choice against a
neighbor
committing unimaginable crimes in the
process
why
not because it was attacked not because
it was threatened not because it but
because it chose to
it has not stopped even when the general
assembly of the of this organization
overwhelmingly condemned its war and
told it to stop
what kind of world would we be living in
if we do not unite
in the face of this
what kind of message would we be sending
to every aspiring dictator and every
regime who for reasons of choice decides
it is not happy with its borders its
geopolitical space or resources
it is also for this reason reason that
russia must be held account to account
and this is something we owe to the
ukrainian people too who in this war are
fighting not just for their lands and
for their country but also for us
for our peace and security and stability
and for the future of us all
accountability is about protecting the
foundations of our system the principles
of the un charter our common values and
our shared responsibility we could not
prevent this conflict but we must not
fail to hold accountable all those
responsible
i would like to give the floor to deputy
minister of uh
foreign affairs of ukraine
to miss emine japarova
who was who has kindly joined us today
in the absence of minister kuleba who
for reasons that we all understand
made it impossible to participate ms
japarova the floor is yours
thank you madam chair
dear friends excellencies colleagues and
partners
i would like to first of all thank the
permanent mission of albania in france
for arranging this meeting and for all
of the briefers
for your kind words of support for your
readiness to act because this is
something that we need
to keep on fighting and believe me i
will take everything back to kiev the
energy of support this is what we need
this is our fuel
i'm addressing you today on behalf of my
home country ukraine
and as a representative of two nations
crimean terrors and ukrainians
that suffered moscow made genocide in
20th century these are holodomor which
is a man-made hunger and famine and
deportation we call it surgun in crimean
tara language
exile of all of the crimean terrors from
their land
and unfortunately today we suffer the
consequences of war and occupation in
the 21st century
the history of my country teaches us are
not brought to accountability
you can expect bigger crimes and
atrocities
when i was a child
my grandmothers used to tell me the
tragic story of deportation
every single family of the crimean
entire nation has survived it when
back in 1944
women children and sinners were put in
the kettle shed wagons and taken to
central asian countries
while men were fighting
within the soviet army
against fascism during the second world
war
moscow back then cynically justified its
crime
that killed almost half of all crimean
terrors
by fake and false allegations of
collaboration with nazi germany
just like russia is doing today hiding
its crime of war behind fakes and
manipulations
many years after i already as a mother
had to explain my daughters why we are
not able to live in crimea anymore in my
homeland after the occupation of 2014
when after russia invaded the peninsula
they started oppressing crimean
terrorists immediately for their
pro-ukrainian stand
the evil we all did not stop eight years
ago became bigger
the beast wants more more land
more blood and more lives
and i never ever thought
that my daughters would probably have to
explain their children
the experience that they have with the
warring occupation and this is really
horrible
my thoughts when i speak here today are
with elizabeth and sonia these are the
two angels small actors of mariupol
theater
killed by russian bombs
as well as with three-month-old kira
and her mother killed by russian missile
in odessa right on the eve of easter
the death of children is always an
unbearable pain
as i'm telling you this
russian armed forces continue to shell
ukrainian cities intensively
they use aerial bombs heavy artillery
missiles
the city of mariupol has turned into
dust
thousands civilians remain in blockade
without water electricity communication
and basic things that all people
need mariupol
erp
these are the series already well known
throughout the world
and what you can see there today and for
example mr karimhan has already attended
the series this is not the netflix
decoration of horror movies this is the
reality that i and many of my
compatriots live in
ukrainian law enforcement board is
revealed and launched investigation into
almost 8 000 war crimes committed by
russian army
new mass graves and burials are being
found almost every day
the final number of russian war crimes
in ukraine will be much higher
especially taking into account how the
russian army behaves itself healing
tortures
rapes
robbing and destroying they even robs
socks
and pants
and toilet boils and the dog houses
we ukrainians fight for
ruled-based world and order and we truly
believe in international law as a
fundamental principle and instrument to
bring all of the criminals to
accountability
that's why we initiated a case in the
icj
against russia on the alleged genocide
we filed all necessary documents just in
two days
after the beginning of the full-fledged
invasion
icj ordered russia to immediately
suspend military operations commenced on
24th of february
but in already a very traditional manner
russia ignored it as it did before
but the floor to act is not only by
russia each and every signatory of the
u.n charter
should demand that it has been respected
that the binding order are to be
implemented
russia must be accountable for its crime
as a state but we all know as miss amal
clooney said that every crime has also a
person who commits it
the one who raped a girl kicking out her
teeth
who killed a man riding a bicycle
who fusilated a queue of people waiting
for bread
who shot humanitarian convoys maternity
hospitals ambulances cars
these people have names and faces and
they they are to be brought to criminal
liability
we appreciate the work done by our
prosecutor general office and the icc
and mr karimhan
and everyone who supports us
ukraine has also endorsed the proposal
of the leading experts in the sphere of
international criminal law to create a
special criminal tribunal for the
punishment of the crime of aggression
against ukraine
i believe that the special criminal
tribunal will complement
the work of the icc in prosecuting
persons responsible for
their crimes
and the preparation of this aggression
its execution initiation and so on
i call on you distinguished colleagues
using this opportunity to consider
thoroughly
creation of such a new mechanism and
support it
even when putin will be defeated i'm
sure he will quite soon
the business as usual with russia could
not be restored without holding
accountable of all perpetrators
the ukrainian leadership will take every
possible effort to bring these people to
justice
this
remaining operational
and we are very proud of our people who
demonstrate amazing bravery
we are proud of our army and even our
president voldemski who has become a
symbol of dignity and human spirit
slava ukrainian
glory to ukraine
[Applause]
i thank you dear eminent for your
statements
it is heartbreaking to see what your
people are going through but it's also
very inspiring to see their heroic
resistance and their bravery as you said
i'd like now to pass the floor to the
organizer of this event the
representative of france for her remarks
dear natalie glory is yours
thank you
thank you mrs chair
and i would like to thank
all the briefers today for their very
powerful statements
i commend the remarkable work of the
prosecutor general of ukraine
of michelle bashley and her teams
of the icc
and of the united nations agencies on
the ground as war is still raging in
ukraine
also pay tribute to the work done by the
civil society
to document crimes committed in
ukraine we also commend the swift
operationalization by the ohc air of the
commission of inquiry on ukraine
for more than two months now
russia has been
killing killing civilians
including women children the elderly
humanitarian and medical workers and
journalists
the number of civilian casualties
that the high commissioner has presented
is absolutely horrific
the images of the attract atrocities
committed in butcher
and other areas previously occupied by
the russian forces and unbearable
these acts may amount to war crimes as
our briefers have underlined
friends is appalled by the killing and
maiming of children
as well as attacks on schools and on
hospitals
and friends comments unfp and all
actress on the ground providing services
to survivors of sexual violence
france is firmly committed to working
with ukraine its
international partners as well as
international jurisdiction and mechanism
to prevent impunity
for these inter-liberal acts
so we welcome the report prepared by
independent experts of the oac moscow
mechanism
which points out to the existence of
very clear patterns
of international human rights violation
by the russian forces in their conduct
of hostilities
the report's conclusion will inform the
investigations that are underway
upon referral of 43 states including
france the icc prosecutor has opened an
investigation into the situation in
ukraine
and we welcome the swift deployment of
icc investigation team on the ground in
ukraine and we have sent two judges and
10 investigators
and made a financial contribution of 500
000 euro to support concretely this team
in addition to the annual funding we
provide for the icc
so following the discovery of mass
atrocities in the areas previously
occupied by russian forces
in the city of butcher in particular
france has deployed a technical team to
provide expertise in id identification
of evidence gathering
those forensic scientists and crime
scene experts are supporting ukrainian
and icc teams on the ground
mr mrs chair the icc is a pillar of the
international rule-based order
it needs support
we call on all states to ratify the rome
stated
mr we call on russia
to respect the order of the icg and stop
its war of aggression against ukraine
the priority remains an immediate
association of hostilities a withdrawal
of all russian troops from the territory
of ukraine and the full respect
of international human humanitarian law
and international human rights law
the protection of civilians is an
absolute imperative in particular in the
besieged mario paul
and humanitarian access must be
guaranteed
mr
france will continue to support ukraine
the ukrainians and all efforts to ensure
the effective investigation
and prosecution
of all those responsible for atrocities
in ukraine and i can assure you those
crimes won't go unpunished
thank you
i thank the representative
of france for her statements as well as
for the very close and excellent
cooperation in the organization of this
meeting
i would
like now to open the floor for the other
members of the security council and the
first on my list is
the us delegation represented by
ambassador at large for global criminal
justice dr beth van der schack
dr van der schak
the floor is yours
thank you madam chair
and thank you to france and albania for
convening us today and for all the
keynote speakers
your work is really critical and will
deeply grateful for all that you do in
this matter
the united states is also quite pleased
to co-sponsor this event this afternoon
it has now been two months
since moscow launched its latest assault
and further aggression on ukraine
as secretary general guterres confirmed
when the war began russia's war against
ukraine is unacceptable it is a manifest
violation of the un charter
russia has failed in its objective of
capturing kiev
and it has failed in his objective of
subjugating ukraine
but we have all still seen the kremlin
inflict massive brutality across the
country
and the united states has assessed that
russia's forces are committing war
crimes in ukraine
this assessment is based upon a careful
and rigorous review of public sources
and also intelligence sources
at first this violence took the form of
what appeared to be deliberate and
indiscriminate attacks against civilians
and
elements of the civilian infrastructure
later however when brave journalists and
human rights defenders and other
elements
and other actors got access to areas
following russia's retreat
we saw violence of a different order
this was interpersonal violence
credible reports of individuals killed
execution style with their hands bound
bodies showing signs of torture
horrific accounts of sexual violence
against women and girls
we now have credible information that a
russian military unit operating in the
vicinity of donetsk executed ukrainians
who were attempting to surrender rather
than take them into custody
if true this would be a violation of the
core principles of the laws of war the
prohibition against the summary
execution of civilians and of combatants
who are all to combat
by virtue of surrender
injury or other forms of incapacitation
these images and reports suggest that
atrocities are not the result of rogue
units or individuals
they rather reveal a deeply disturbing
pattern
of systematic abuse across all areas
where russia's forces are engaged
let us be clear those who unleashed
perpetratored and ordered these crimes
must be held to account and the evidence
of this criminality is mounting daily
our simple message to russia's military
and political leadership and to the rank
and file
is this
the world is watching and you will be
held accountable
the united states is supporting a range
of international investigations into
atrocities in ukraine this includes
those conducted by the international
criminal court
the united nations and the organization
for security and cooperation in europe
the united states welcomes the opening
of the investigation
by the icc into atrocity crimes
committed in ukraine and we intend to
engage in all stakeholders engage with
all stakeholders to achieve our common
objectives in ensuring justice
with many european partners the united
states is also supporting the ukrainian
national authorities and specifically
the war crimes units of the office of
the prosecutor general
as they investigate and prepare
to prosecute war crimes cases in
ukrainian courts
we are funding a multinational team of
experts and other war crimes prosecutors
deployed to the region
this international this
interdisciplinary team is providing
advice and support to ukrainians to
ukraine's prosecutor general to collect
preserve and analyze evidence of
atrocities with a view towards achieving
criminal accountability
these individuals bring years of
experience at the international war
crimes tribunals in the investigation
and prosecution of international
and they will be supporting their
ukrainian counterparts as they build
their own case files and we welcome
other states to join in this effort
we also stand ready to support national
courts around the world as in the event
that they seek to establish jurisdiction
over individuals accused of committing
international crimes
and of course we welcome and will
support proceedings before the
international court of justice and the
european court of human rights which are
both adjudicating state responsibility
we will also continue to assist with
documentation efforts
we helped to establish the human rights
council commission of inquiry ensuring
that it had a strong mandate to
investigate document and analyze
violations of international humanitarian
law and human rights
share those that information with
appropriate judicial bodies
and to identify the individuals and
entities who are responsible
we also joined 44 osce participating
states in invoking the the moscow
mechanism fact-finding mission
the experts report released on april
13th has provided a meticulous and
compelling account of russia's
violations and abuses
within ukraine
it also cites evidence of the direct
targeting of civilians attacks on
medical facilities rape executions
looting and forced deportations of
citizens to russia
all of the information collected by
these experts will be made available to
the relevant accountability mechanisms
as well as any courts that may have
jurisdiction now or in the future may
exercise that jurisdiction
and the regular updates from the u.n
human rights monitoring mission on the
ground in ukraine have greatly informed
our understanding of the situation and
we can commend the mission mission in
continuing to document civilian
casualties and damage to civilian
objects
as the high commissioner for human
rights herself acknowledged the actual
number of casualties is much higher than
what appears in published reports
we will no doubt learn learn more as the
horrors inflicted in areas of intense
fighting such as mario paul come to
light
finally as part of our effort to advance
accountability in ukraine the united
states has released information on the
immediate priorities of the european
democrat democratic resilience
initiative
announced by president biden during his
visit to to brussels in march this
initiative will provide up to 320
million dollars in new funding to
support societal resilience and to
defend human rights including through
supporting accountability related
projects together each and every one of
these institutions and mechanisms make
up
a system interlinked of international
justice
at the same time and on other fronts the
united states and other states have been
working together to implement sanctions
on russia's leadership as well as
private individuals and entities in
order to strengthen ukraine's hand
starve russia of the resources it has
been using to prosecute this unprovoked
war of aggression
and encourage individuals subject to
sanction to dramatically change course
and finally in close cooperation with
our allies and partners the united
states has taken action through the
general assembly three times most
recently to overwhelmingly vote to oust
russia from the human rights council
we now all occupy
a unique historical moment when there is
a global consensus that the conduct of
the russian state is intolerable and
those in command and control must not go
unpunished for unleashing such violence
and brutality and for violating
international peace and security
at this critical moment we must continue
to coordinate international and
multinational lines of effort to advance
the interlocking imperatives of justice
and accountability to preserve the
sanctions of international norms to hold
accountable those responsible and to
respond to the victims legitimate
demands and desires for justice
we already have regional and
international accountability
institutions in place it is now up to us
to remain coordinated and single-minded
in our efforts
russia will predictably veto any effort
by the council to hold it accountable
for these atrocities but as ambassador
thomas greenfield recently said in the
council russia cannot veto
accountability
in closing i know that the vast majority
of members today believe that the people
of ukraine should be able to live their
lives without having the fear of their
homes being destroyed by a russian shell
or being shot with their hands tied
behind their back and left dying on the
street
effective accountability measures for
those who are ordering and committing
atrocities will make clear that those
who engage in brutality will not enjoy
impunity
together with ukraine
and our allies and partners we are
united and in our resolve to bring
perpetrators to justice thank you madam
chair
i thank dr shock for her strong
statement and intervention i now give
the floor to the representative of the
united kingdom ambassador you have the
floor
thank you madam chair and may i start by
thanking albania france and ukraine for
convening today's arya formula meeting
and also extending thanks to all of our
briefers
in particular
i want to convey the uk's solidarity and
support to deputy foreign minister
japarova and through her to the
ukrainian government and people
russia's attacks on civilians in ukraine
constitute war crimes
the uk is determined
that those responsible be held
accountable i'd like to make three
points
about international coordination
evidence collection
and sexual violence
first
the uk is supporting international
efforts to see justice delivered
we're supporting the international
criminal court's work
and will provide 1 million pounds of
additional funding
the uk also supports
the human rights council commission of
inquiry
the osce council of europe and european
court of human rights
in their work
to ensure all allegations of atrocity
crimes
are thoroughly investigated
but as ida sawyer eloquently reminded us
we must ensure that these efforts are
coordinated and complementary
second
the evidence that's collected
must be collected urgently and properly
to ensure it meets the appropriate
standard for future prosecutions
the uk has appointed leading war crimes
lawyer sir howard morrison
to support the ukrainian prosecutor
general's own investigations
and the metropolitan police have set up
an online reporting tool for witnesses
including refugees
to submit their evidence
third
we must ensure accountability for
conflict-related sexual violence
this is an issue
on which the uk has partnered especially
closely with prosecutor khan
and miss clooney and we're grateful for
your dedication and commitment
the foreign secretary has launched a 10
million pound civil society fund
to support organizations in ukraine
including those helping survivors of
sexual violence
and the morad code
launched earlier this month
provides important guidelines for
interviewing survivors of sexual
violence
and we welcome
that it will be applied with respect to
ukraine
as we've heard
every day
more deeply disturbing reports of sexual
violence emerge
mass graves where women were raped
before being killed
bodies so disfigured
they would be impossible to identify
[Music]
the perpetrators
of these horrors and crimes
those who have directed them
and those who have carried them out
the mass executions
rapes
and mutilations of innocent men and
women
will face justice
it is our duty to the victims and
survivors
and as prosecutor khan said
to humanity
i thank you madam chair
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom and i give the floor to the
representative of ireland ambassador you
have the floor
thank you very much indeed minister
thank you madam chair and thanks to
albanian france also for organizing
today's discussion we're really proud
to be a co-sponsor of such an important
exchange i'd like to thank all our
briefers
their their presentations were powerful
but they were also stark at times
appropriately so
madam chair it said that all it takes
for evil to triumph is for good men i
would argue good women to say nothing
in the face of russia's unlawful and
unjustifiable further invasion of
ukraine the members of this house of the
united nations cannot afford to say
nothing we cannot afford to stay quiet
and that's why many of us are stepping
in
where the security council has failed
and we are speaking out forcefully
however
as the true horror of the atrocities
allegedly committed in ukraine come to
light
disapprobation is simply not enough
as irish minister simon coveny told the
security council last week there are
rules even in war
and when those rules are broken there
must be accountability
that is why timely credible
investigations are so vital
it is why evidence must be rigorously
documented it is why witnesses victims
and survivors must be supported
madam chair we contend that the scope
for impunity is diminishing
in contrast to 20 years ago the
international criminal court now stands
as the first permanent international
court with the power to prosecute
atrocity crimes including those
happening in ukraine
ireland joined over 40 states to refer
the situation in ukraine to the icc
recognizing the pressure this
investigation would place on the court
we are also committing additional
funding to assist in the investigation
of all situations before the icc
we welcome the announcement by the
office of the prosecutor that it will
participate in the joint investigation
team on alleged core international
crimes committed in ukraine that will
help to ensure cooperation coordination
and collective action between the icc
and national authorities including in
ukraine
and just today we have heard powerful
statement from the prosecutor general of
ukraine speaking to the scale of her
office's investigation of russian war
crimes
however notwithstanding these efforts
towards accountability
notwithstanding the provisional measures
indicated by the international court of
justice
russia's aggression continues unabated
russia has not only ignored
international humanitarian law but in
the words of the high commissioner it
has tossed it aside
from the reporting of the osce moscow
mechanisms mission of experts we can now
see clear patterns of violations of
international humanitarian law by russia
evidence of such violations continues to
mount
from the destruction of mariopol
hospital by russian airstrikes to
indiscriminate attacks and kramatosk
train station we have seen mass graves
being excavated in bucha and elsewhere
we have heard harrowing reports of
conflict-related sexual violence which
we also must stress can constitute a war
crime
there can be no impunity for such abuse
the human rights monitoring mission has
recorded over five thousand civilian
casualties in ukraine an appalling
figure which we know
doesn't reflect yet those casualties in
areas of such intense fighting such as
mariopol idiom and papashna where
reports of abominable summary executions
of civilians are emerging
madam chair ireland is fully committed
to accountability for
these heinous actions and for those
which have yet to be uncovered
moving ahead as ida saw ida
sawyer
pointed out earlier cooperation and
coordination of all our accountability
efforts will be key
for this reason we want to acknowledge
today the efforts here by the group of
friends on accountability in ukraine to
coordinate and share information on
existing and emerging accountability
initiatives
we welcome the work by eurojust and the
eu advisory mission to ensure that
domestic and international
investigations are supported and mr
moses statement today that the
commission will be reaching out to the
icc prosecutor is also very important
as i conclude madam chair i would like
to say a word directly to ukrainian
women and men who today must be
harboring doubts that justice will ever
be delivered
i deeply regret that the security
council has failed
we have failed in our collective duty to
prevent conflict and maintain peace in
ukraine
we all know why
however
even as this unjustified war continues
there are those amongst us who will not
stop trying
there are those who will continue to
demand justice for the crimes committed
i want to recall the words of the great
nelson mandela who remarked it always
seems impossible until it's done
from rwanda to cambodia bosnia to sierra
leone
accountability for such crimes once may
have seemed impossible
until it was done
rest assured that ireland will work
tirelessly to ensure
you the women and men of ukraine that
you too obtain justice
the perpetrators of these heinous crimes
will be held to account
we owe you nothing less thank you madam
chair
i thank the representative of ireland
and give the floor to the representative
or uae
madam chair
i thank the permanent missions of
albania and france for organizing this
arya formula meeting
as well as all the panelists for their
participation and contributions
the uae is deeply concerned by the
continued fighting in ukraine and the
rapidly deteriorating humanitarian
situation on the ground this conflict
has again laid bare the terrible human
costs of war and those costs are largely
borne by millions of civilians in
particular women and children
but as we know
its repercussions are increasingly felt
beyond the borders of ukraine
we along with the rest of the
international community have been
shocked by the reports and images that
we have seen coming out of ukraine over
the past weeks
including of alleged targeting and
summary executions of civilians
conflict-related sexual violence and the
destruction of civilian infrastructure
the uae reiterates its call on all
parties to uphold international
humanitarian law and international human
rights law and we strongly condemn all
atrocities
and violations of these laws in all
their forms
accountability
is not optional it is essential
achieving justice for victims and
survivors effectively fighting impunity
and deterring future atrocities requires
properly instituted mechanisms and
processes
establishing the facts and circumstances
in an impartial manner and beyond any
doubt or dispute is both fundamental and
difficult as we have seen in other cases
therefore it is critical to ensure the
proper investigation of alleged crimes
focusing on fact-finding and data
collection
we underline that the primary
responsibility for accountability lies
at the national level and appropriate
authorities should be given the space
needed to fulfill that responsibility
we encourage support for domestic rule
of law institutions
and investigative processes and note the
importance of providing such support in
cooperation with national officials
as a member of the
human rights council the uae voted in
favor of resolution 49-1
establishing the independent
international commission of inquiry on
ukraine with a mandate that includes
investigating all alleged violations and
abuses of human rights and international
humanitarian law
as well as documenting and verifying
relevant information and evidence
we know that investigative mechanisms
are complex and can take considerable
time to deliver on their mandate however
effective accountability demands it
in the meantime we must focus on saving
lives and reducing suffering by
achieving an immediate cessation of
hostilities in ukraine and finding a
diplomatic resolution to this conflict i
thank you madam chair
i thank the representative of uae and
give the floor to the representative of
kenya
thank you
excellency
and minister
let me also thank the
permanent missions of albania france and
ukraine for organizing this important
discussion
i acknowledge the presence of the deputy
minister of foreign affairs of ukraine
madame charapova
and i thank the previous for their
shared perspectives
chairperson
at the heart of today's meeting
is the pressing need to stand in
solidarity with the people of ukraine
who are bearing the brands of the
failure of the global military order to
keep the world safe from the scourge of
war
this discussion is therefore an
opportunity to reaffirm
our resolve
to keep alive the purposes of the united
nations
particularly as set out and article one
of the united nations charter
kenya maintains that
if multilateralism is to deliver
sustained peace to all
then the most powerful states must
adhere to international law
and respect for the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of all countries
in all regions
at all times
thus
the continuing bridge of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity by
the russian federation
cannot be justified by any reason
we've had reports of loss of thousands
of lives
and continuing suffering of millions in
and out of ukraine because of this war
we've also heard reports of massive
damage and destruction of civilian
infrastructure
in violation of international law
and international humanitarian law
therefore
as it should be in any case of violation
of international law the call for
investigations
for accountability for violations that
may be unfolding in ukraine
is justified
as part
of the delivery of justice for the
people of ukraine
and considering that ensuring
accountability is largely a legal
undertaking we propose that the
following elements be taken into
consideration
one
there has to be a united call for
accountability and coherence among the
relevant u.n agencies and bodies in line
with article 1 4 of the u.n charter
second
the independence of investigations must
be safeguarded at all times particularly
against and due politicization to ensure
credibility and objectivity
and third there will be need for strong
support for ukrainian national
investigative
and judicial mechanisms
especially in securing
possible crime scenes
preservation of evidence
and protection of witnesses
having said this chair
it is our considered view
that accountability should also be
pursued within the broader and more
comprehensive context of conflict
resolution
it is therefore critical
not to lose focus on the need to stop
the war through the prioritized and
sequenced activities that entail among
others
cessation of hostilities
achieving a permanent ceasefire and
initiating a viable political process
for conflict resolution
identifying and addressing the root
causes in order to work towards
sustainable outcomes for the peace
process
addressing the consequences of conflict
including gross human rights abuses and
international crimes
and finally ensuring meaningful
participation of all parties involved
and essential stakeholders including
women and youth to conclude aria farm
kenya solidarity
with the people of ukraine and our
support for the sovereignty territorial
integrity and political independence of
ukraine i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya and
give the floor to the representative of
india
thank you madam chair
for their updates on the topic of
today's meeting
we continue to remain deeply concerned
at the worsening situation in ukraine
and reiterate call for immediate
cessation of violence
and into hostilities
we believe that no solution can be
arrived at by shedding blood and at the
cost of innocent lives
we have emphasized right from the
beginning of the conflict the need to
pursue the path of diplomacy and
dialogue
we have unequivocally condemned the
reported killings in bhusha and
reiterate our support for the call for
an independent investigation
we welcome u.n secretary general's
ongoing visit in the region including to
moscow and queue and have taken positive
note of his discussions with the parties
on humanitarian corridors in ukraine
especially in mari maria paul
india has been at the forefront of
protecting human rights from its
inception including in the drafting of
the universal declaration of human
rights
we firmly believe that all decision
should be taken respecting due process
as all our democratic polity and
structures enjoin us to do
this applies to the international
organizations as well including the
united nations
let me also place on record that india
is not a party to the rome statute
we continue to emphasize to all member
states of the un that the global order
is anchored on international law u.n
charter and respect for territorial
integrity and sovereignty of state
it is in our collective interest to work
constructively
both inside the united nations and
outside towards seeking an early
solution solution
to the conflict in ukraine i thank you
i thank the representative of india and
give the floor to the representative of
norway
thank you to madame chair and many
thanks to to albania and france for uh
committing this meeting
we join others as well in thanking
today's briefers for clearly underlining
the need for accountability for
atrocities committed
in ukraine
and for shedding light on the different
mechanisms and initiatives being
undertaken to ensure this
the u.n charter applies to all nations
including russia
yet there is no doubt that russia's
invasion of ukraine is a blatant
violation of international law including
the u.n charter
hanoi is appalled by russia's methods of
warfare
numerous credible reports have described
it in horrible detail the relentless
attacks against civilians
these atrocities shock the very
consciousness
and conscience of humanity
non-combat combatants including women
children and refugees have become
victims and vital civilian
infrastructure leveled
in blatant violations of international
law
it is imperative that we hold all
perpetrators to account through both
credible national and international
criminal justice
mechanisms accountability is key
both to ensure that the victims and to
deter and prevent future violations
appropriate mechanisms are therefore
necessary to gather evidence and to
adjust
educate
these
those committing atrocities must know
that their actions will never be
forgotten war crimes will be
investigated and individuals at all
levels held to account for their actions
dear colleagues
we are grateful for today's briefing by
the prosecutor of the icc
and are pleased that this office has
initiated investigations of possible war
crimes and crimes against humanity
committed in ukraine
norway remains a strong supporter of the
icc and was among the unprecedented
number of 43 states referring the
situation in ukraine to the courts
there can be no doubt that the icc's
mission remains as crucial as ever both
in the context of ukraine and globally
norway underscores the also the
importance of the ruling of the
international court of justice last
month which clearly and unequivocally
ordered russia to immediately suspend
its military operations in ukraine
russia's disregard of this significant
ruling which uh
russia
the disregard of this significant ruling
which is it is obliged to heed is
deplorable
norway also welcomes the establishment
of the commission of inquiry on ukraine
by the human rights council
which is mandated to investigate
violations and abuses on human rights
and violations of international
humanitarian law in the context of
ukraine we expect that the commission
will identify individuals and entities
responsible for violations and
contribute to holding them to accounts
i don't chair
we have a common interest in ensuring
that the perpetrators of international
crimes do not escape
with impunity
therefore
the adoption of the general assembly of
the resolution aggression against
ukraine calling all parties to strictly
respect the relevant provisions of
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law it's an
important signal from the international
community
and norway commenced the founders of the
group of friends for accountability in
ukraine
for creating a valuable platform to
engage and promote synergies between the
various measures that are being
initiated at
national regional and international
level
to ensure accountability in ukraine
dear friends and colleagues to end let
me reiterate
accountability
is essential
violations of international law cannot
go unchallenged international law is not
optional
thank you madam chair
i thank the representative of norway and
give the floor to the representative of
brazil
thank you madam chair
at the outset
brazil would like to thank albania and
france for organizing this meeting
we would love we would also like to
thank the briefers
for their contribution to this debate
brazil would like to draw attention to
the fact that in order to ensure an
order based on international law a
fundamental task must be taken up
to defend its integrity at all times and
in all situations
international law must prevail
especially when international crimes and
internationally wrongful acts are
committed by individuals and states
this is why the rules of the criminal
accountability and international
responsibility must lie at the epicenter
of any legal regime
over the years the international
community has built a solid legal system
to hold individuals accountable for
their crimes
the rome statute regime
international criminal justice is a
solution only when states which
jurisdiction are unwilling or unable to
act
complementarity is one of the
cornerstones of the roman statute regime
such principle
shows that it's imperative to build a
culture of accountability at the
national level with strong judicial
judicial institutions that are able to
fight impunity
cooperation is also one of the key tools
in ensuring successful outcomes
by the international criminal court
as a founder of the icc
brazil supports its work
to promote accountability at the
international level for perpetrators
as well as preparations for the victims
brazil also highlights the value of
having a permanent
street-based tribunal
advancing the universality of the rome
statute would be a fundamental
contribution to ensuring accountability
in the international community
we call on all states to ratify the rome
institute and to fully cooperate with
the icc
if the universality of the rome
institute is achieved
especially amongst the permanent members
of the security council
there would be a more fertile ground for
justice and instability in the
international legal system
another point
we would like to raise is the gap
between the growing workload of the icc
and the resources available to it in its
regular budget
this gap
is widened by the current situation
in which
only states parties cover the cost of
security council referrals
we hope this can be solved in a fair and
sustainable manner
we also hope that the recent call for
voluntary contribution
contributions will not lead to
selectivity in the work of the court
all victims should be prioritized
equally
the icc was established
to allow for the promotion of
international criminal justice in a
non-selective manner
states must refrain from the threat or
use of force
against the territorial integrity or
political independence of any state
or in any other manner inconsistent with
the u.n charter
unfortunately the international
community has witnessed several attempts
and violations of article 2.4 of the u.n
charter over the past decades and is
still today
this is a line that should never
should never be crossed if crossed norms
related to international accountability
and responsibility must prevail
to conclude
i would like to recall that brazil voted
in favor of the human rights council
resolution that created an independent
commission of inquiry on ukraine to
assess and review the facts on the
ground
we trust that this mechanism will
establish the effects and circumstances
that may amount to violations of
international law in ukraine
the proper documentation of alleged
crimes is the first step in ensuring
individual criminal
criminal accountability and i thank you
i thank the representative of brazil and
give the floor to the representative of
mexico
thank you very much madam chair and
giving the long list of speakers i'll
try to be brief
madame chair excellencies i'll begin as
everyone else thanking albania and
france for convening this meeting and
also in thanking all the panelists for
their remarks
as we have heard reports on the
situation in ukraine
suggest that we are facing great
breaches of international human rights
and international humanitarian law and
the images of possible mass graves in
mariopol are simply alarming as a result
of russia's aggression in ukraine mexico
supported as well the establishment of
the independent international commission
of inquiry by the human rights council
as well as the judicial processes both
in the international criminal court and
international court of justice in order
to adjudicate prosecute and punish those
responsible for war crimes crimes
against humanity or genocide from the
angles both of individual and state
responsibility and since mention has
been made on the importance to take
action rather than just to say words
i also want to to recall that together
with france we brought together to the
general assembly a resolution on the
humanitarian access
in ukraine which was adopted again with
an overwhelming majority
in this context also i would also wish
to reiterate the importance of the
french mexican initiative on the
voluntary restraint of the veto in cases
of mass atrocities which is now
supported by 105 states
this number may sound very high but it
is in these types of situations that we
recognize that this is the moment in
which we should reassess and and
reconsider
the the adherence to this important
initiative and we invite those states
that have not yet done so to reconsider
uh joining and to use this time to sign
as well
in order to promote and ensure
accountability at the national and
international levels
it is also of the utmost importance to
launch this fall a process to negotiate
and adopt at convention to prevent and
punish crimes against humanity based on
the draft articles that were adopted by
the international law commission and we
hope that we can get action this october
or november
and to conclude
accountability for international crimes
should always be the norm regardless of
where they are committed so to be clear
all international crimes wherever and
whenever perpetrated are equally grave
and should equally be punished
in this regard we call on all states
that support the call for accountability
in ukraine and elsewhere to adhere to
the rome statute and to accept the
compulsory jurisdiction of the
international court of justice
this has been mentioned by several
delegations today
mexico is proud to belong to the group
of states that have done this but we
believe that this is only congruent with
the message and calls that we have heard
today and in the past weeks thank you
i thank the representative of mexico and
i give the floor to the representative
of china
i thank you madam president
china's position on the ukraine issue
has been consistent and clear
we believe the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of all countries
including ukraine should be respected
the purpose and principles of the u.n
charter should be upheld
the legitimate security concerns of all
countries should be taken seriously
and all efforts conducive to a peaceful
settlement of the crisis should be
supported
the prospect of a prolonged and extended
conflict is worrying
we're especially saddened to see the
reports on civilian casualties and
killings
under international humanitarian law
civilians should be spared of any forms
of violence in armed conflicts
attacks against civilians are
unacceptable and should not occur
the related circumstances and specific
causes of civilian deaths should be
verified and established
at the same time
any acquisition should be based on facts
before the full picture is clear
all sides should access restraint and
avoid unfunded accusations
dialogue and negotiation is the only way
out for peace
china kausang russia and ukraine to
adhere to the direction of dialogue and
negotiation
overcome difficulties and differences
and accumulate conditions for an early
ceasefire
the international community should focus
on supporting diplomatic
negotiations and do more to ease the
tensions
instead of aggravating conflicts
we welcome secretary general guterres
visit to russia and ukraine and support
him in his diplomatic engagement with
all parties
china will continue its constructive
efforts in solving the ukraine crisis i
thank you
madam chair
i thank the representative of china and
give the floor to the representative of
the russian federation
thank you so much
many of the participants of the today's
meeting praised international criminal
court which
is interesting
um since at least two of the co-sponsors
of today's meeting the united states and
the united kingdom did everything
imaginable to shield their own military
from the icc's rich both countries
developed protective legislation
american law is so
far that
it was nicknamed western legal
professionals as the hague invasion act
political pressure
financial leverage and even imposing
personal sanctions on the icc prosecutor
all these led to the desired outcome
investigations into war crimes committed
by soldiers of these countries in iraq
and afghanistan were quote unquote
deprioritized by icc
this is a rather sophisticated term for
a very simple thing namely not doing
anything
this perfectly illustrates
both the real degree of icc's
impartiality and objectivity
as well as hypocrisy of us and uk all of
a sudden started to support
the court and poor millions of dollar
dollars there as the nations
such an attitude turns justice into foss
paid for verdicts by paid for court
international perception of icc's role
and stance was well demonstrated by
ukraine
its declaration on acceptance of its
jurisdiction dated 8th september 2015
represents an ill ill-famous attempt not
only to limit the court's jurisdiction
but also to assign the blame in advance
before a formal investigation even
started
like we said
icc
is a merely political instrument
and has nothing in common with justice
in light of today's remarks of the high
commission on human rights we would like
to note that it has become a tradition
for various fact-finding missions
established by ohchr to conduct their
business without physical presence in
their respective country in this regard
their methods of work presuppose
reliance on information provided by ngos
as well as available in the open domain
namely the internet working in this
manner it's literally impossible to
disqu distinguish between the truth and
myriads of fakes
we would be hesitant to draw any
conclusions based on information of that
quality
today we also heard about role of ngos
and civil society this role has indeed
been very prominent the west mobilized a
real fake news factory to produce
new lives 24 7 to create a parallel
reality of what is happening in ukraine
all of the fakes mentioned today were
refuted multiple times
butcher vacation by the way got a new
twist
according to the guardian most victims
were not cold-bloodedly shot as it had
been claimed for at least three weeks
already but rather killed by artillery
anti-personnel shells filled with small
dots called flechettes
from the
french word standing for a small arrow
it's the same type of
shell that ukraine has been using to
bombard donbass since 2014
there is a lot of evidence about that in
the internet
it seems that western media will have to
forget the word butcher just as quickly
as they forgot and banned the word
kramatorsk
it was another prominent fake everyone
from day one had been confidently
blaming russia for a missile strike on
the railway station killing 50 and
injuring 100 civilians
until the serial number of the missile
surfed surfaced
in the social networks identifying it
beyond any doubt as ukrainian used by
the same military unit that bombarded
civilian targets in dambass
anyone is raising the issue about
ukraine's accountability for kramatosk
now
any ngos or civil society or maybe
mainstream media
complete and shameful or rather
shameless silence
and so we thought
what we heard today was another portion
of unsubstantiated claims and even fakes
seasoned with lies hypocrisy and pompous
rhetoric
if you want to learn the truth about
real situation on the ground come to our
area formula meeting on may 6. we plan
to give the floor to some independent
voices working on the front line to
demonstrate you facts not fakes
lastly i would like to stress
the flow of fake news will not shield
ukrainian neo-nazis foreign mercenaries
and their sponsors from accountability
for heinous crimes
multiple witness statements and evidence
to that effect are being collected right
now across ukraine including in mariupol
witnesses confirm inter-alia
routine
military use by ukraine military and
nationalist battalions of schools and
even kindergartens as well as other
civilian objects ukrainian military are
not ashamed to do that they post photos
of their military positions there online
i used to collect such posts as evidence
but stop doing that because they were
way too numerous
and just keep coming
ukrainian military and nationalist
battalions also routinely use civilians
as human shields on the extent compared
only to isis tactics but here it's even
worse
because ukrainian military are doing
that to their compatriots
and yes torture centers in 21st century
are truly unthinkable
there is
uh a lot of factual evidence as well as
witness statements about sbu is
operated secret torture center in
mariupol airport it was cynically named
the library
and it was created in 2014 where when
azov nationalist battalion
moved into mariupol this specific center
was used to torture rape and kill the
books
that's how neo-nazis called
the prisoners there ordinary civilians
who were suspected of being non-loyal to
kiev regime
rest assured
perpetrators of these and all other
heinous crimes
will be brought to justice
no one will escape personal
responsibility and the nasification of
ukraine will be completed i thank you
after hearing
the representative of the russian
federation i now give the floor to the
representative of ghana
madam chair and minister of foreign
affairs of albania
i thank you for giving me the flow and
express appreciation for your
delegations organization of this area
formula meeting
i also acknowledge the presence of her
excellency amin jabarova the deputy
foreign minister of ukraine my
delegation has taken note of the
briefings by miss michel bashalit the
united nations high commissioner for
human rights and mr karim khan the
prosecutor of the international criminal
court we also thank all the other
briefers for their contributions to this
discussion
like any other war
the war in ukraine has regrettably
brought to the surface the ugliness of
conflict and its adverse impact on
innocent civilian populations
in situations of war there are many
things that get out of control and it is
in this context that we reiterate
alcohol
we reiterate our call for emphasis to be
placed on the diplomatic track in
addressing the situation in ukraine
a protraction of the conflict risk
degeneration and further complication of
realign global interest which could have
dire impact on the people of ukraine
the war has however seen the
perpetration of violations that need to
be brought into the realm of
accountability
the reported incidents of atrocious
breaches of the sanctity of the rules of
international law that govern the
conduct of modern warfare cannot be left
in the sphere of impunity
it has implications for the victims the
course of justice and the maintenance of
peace and security
consequently we reiterate our position
on the need to conduct thorough
transparent and independent
investigations to establish the facts
and build relevant evidence for the
prosecution of all persons whose acts of
commission or omission during the war in
ukraine constitute crimes under
international law
also
we underscore the need for timely
collection and preservation of empirical
information and data to support an
effective accountability mechanism
the highly fluid situation in ukraine
demands timely gathering of evidence
that would be admissible for the
purposes of attributing international
criminal cri international crimes to
suspected perpetrators
the media and civil society
notwithstanding the personal risk
they're exposed to have made efforts to
pace-takingly document real-time
evidence which could enhance the
prospects for successful prosecutions
such sources need to be properly vetted
and documented for purposes of
prosecution
furthermore multilateral cooperation
remains a crucial element for ensuring
accountability for the international
crimes and violations that have been
committed in ukraine
both political and financial support of
the international community are needed
to ensure the greatest measure of
successful prosecution
additionally enhanced coordination and
cooperation among member states and with
regional bodies would be necessary to
avoid duplications
overburdening witnesses and to ensure
cost effectiveness
in concluding we encourage the
development of the capacity for the
office of the prosecutor
general of ukraine in federance of her
vowed commitment to uphold the laws and
deliver justice to all ukrainian people
who require it in this extraordinary and
painful circumstances
international support would be needed to
bring this very difficult task to
fruition i thank you for giving me the
flow
i thank the representative of ghana and
i now give the floor to the
representative of gabon
i wish to thank albania and france
for organizing this important area
formula meeting
i also wish to join
other security council members
in thanking the briefers for their
contributions
i wish to quote the high commissioner
mrs bashley
the icc prosecutor
the prosecutor of ukraine
the lawyer mrs amal clooney human rights
lawyer
and mrs kenneth ruff from civil society
as well as human rights watched
gabon is in principle in favor
of all initiatives
that are aiming at establishing
violations of international law
covenants
such as
international humanitarian law
international human rights law
and international law for refugees
in this regard
and based on the recommendations
of secretary general of the united
nations
we believe all efforts
should be geared toward
establishing alleged crimes
crimes committed
in the context of the war in ukraine
it would be important
that in this dedicated endeavor
any step should be taken to make sure
the process is exempt
from exasperation
strategic bias
partiality
and propaganda
we support any an independent inquiry
through the entire process
at the end of which
the process of assuring accountability
could only be taken
we look forward
to working closely with other members
from security council and general
assembly
in attempting
to solve this spending
and unnecessary matter
merci thank you
i thank the representative of gabon and
i would now um like to open the floor to
members
of the u.n who wish to take the floor
given the late hour we would be very
grateful if you could limit
your statements to
two minutes
or
submit your statements in writing we
will be circulating a summary of all
interventions of this aria formula
meeting so you're welcome to submit the
full version of your statement in
writing i would like to
give now the floor to the representative
of the european union ambassador you
have the floor
i appreciate
that and i appreciate the late hour and
i appreciate the fact that we need to be
brief and that the purpose of today's
conversation is to listen to the
excellent briefers
and to try to define what action is
needed to assure accountability so i
will skip the parts of my statement that
were a description of the situation
because i think the briefers had done
that in in all its details horrendous as
much of it is but let's remember the
starting point here the general assembly
has asked for russia to cease
hostilities
about what we have seen is intensified
shelling of schools hospitals and
residential buildings the perpetrators
need to be held to account and i agree
with everyone who has said that this is
not just about the situation in ukraine
the accountability for atrocity crimes
committed anywhere in the world should
be
followed up
but today focus is is on ukraine so what
do we do moving forward well i think um
one
starting point is to back up the icc
prosecutor
and we welcome the work that he's been
doing so let's back him up
secondly um we need to launch
investigations at national level the
national prosecutors of lithuania poland
and ukraine have joined efforts into a
joint investigation team enabling them
to exchange information and facilitate
investigation into war crimes crimes
against humanity and other core crimes
the european union agency for criminal
justice corporation era just as somehow
mentioned supports this joint
investigation team
furthermore we have as the eu amended at
the mandate of the advisory mission in
ukraine so that it can provide support
to the office of the prosecutor general
and law enforcement agencies to
facilitate the investigation and
prosecution of international crimes the
advisory mission deploys 350 personnel
to support civilian security sector
reform since 2014 and of course it will
coordinate closely with the icc and the
euro just
there is massive body of evidence of
alleged war crimes and crimes against
humanity being committed by the russian
military forces bucha borodianca mario
paul kramatorsk the list is long
so let's get the facts and as the
prosecutor said let's cling to the law
colleagues it's important to pool our
efforts to gather evidence collect
testimonies to enable prosecution we
support all measures to ensure
accountability for human rights
violation and abuses and violations of
international human
humanitarian law
in this regard we welcome also the
establishment of the commission of
inquiry that commission still needs
support in funding in the fifth uh
committee here in the u.n
ukraine's prosecutor general has asked
for international help in gathering
evidence we are grateful to all states
that have lent their support by
financial contributions by seconding
experts to icc
and to enlarge the investigation timor
by sending forensic experts on the
ground investigators from eu member
states have arrived in kiev and lev to
assist the ukrainian counterparts
states cooperation is necessary to
ensure that national prosecution and the
icc can perform the task they have been
entrusted with and that justice is
served information sharing coordination
among different accountability
mechanisms is also crucial as many have
said
finally the support also by non-state
parties to the icc is welcomed this
demonstrates the international
community's resolved that the victims of
the war in ukraine will not be forget
forgotten and that their harrowing
stories will be heard in court justice
is slow sometimes frustratingly so but
by working for accountability today we
will
get there and hopefully also prevent
further escalation and for and further
dissuade further crimes i thank you very
much madam chair
i thank the representative of the eu and
would now like to give the screen to the
minister of denmark who will be
delivering a pre-recorded statement on
behalf of the group of friends on
accountability in ukraine
i'm pleased to deliver this statement on
behalf of the group of friends of
accountability following the aggression
against ukraine consisting of 48 member
states
and the european union
since the 24th of february we have
witnessed images and reports of numerous
atrocities including indiscriminate
killings of civilians women children and
elderly as well as attacks on civilian
infrastructure we are horrified by the
reports from butcher the strike on the
kramatorsk railway station and the
widespread reports of sexual and
gender-based violence
as underlined by the un secretary
general such attacks are cross
violations of international humanitarian
law and international human rights law
for which the perpetrators must be held
accountable the prosecutor of the
international criminal court is already
investigating this situation
the u.n commission on the of inquiry on
ukraine will investigate violations of
human rights and international
humanitarian law and the three experts
appointed under the osce moscow
mechanism have recently delivered their
report citing a clear pattern of
violations of international humanitarian
law and the basic human rights by
russian forces
these efforts are complemented by
national investigations
and the important work carried out on
the ground by ocha and civil society or
actors to collect
and preserve evidence
the group of friends will support these
efforts to bring war criminals to
justice
we acknowledge this journey can
sometimes be long and costly it can take
years
and we will be there to sustain the
process
no matter how many years
while we pursue the legal path of
accountability the un security council
and general assembly can and should
express their concerns and condemnation
of the unprovoked acts of aggression the
attacks on innocent civilians and
civilian infrastructure reports of human
rights violations and breaches of
humanitarian law
our quest for justice our fight against
impunity for violations of international
law should not must not and cannot be
pursued without collectively taking a
stand against a powerful aggressor
it is therefore only appropriate to
react politically in real time against
russia given credible reports that its
military forces are committing
atrocities against civilians
today we underline the importance of
ensuring accountability for these crimes
without accountability crimes will
continue and impunity will persist
undermining legitimacy
and the prospect for future peace and
reconciliation thank you
i thank uh foreign minister corford for
his statement on behalf of the group of
friends i give the floor to the
permanent representative of finland to
deliver a statement on behalf of nordic
countries ambassador the floor is yours
madam chair i have the honor to speak on
behalf of the five nordic countries
denmark iceland norway sweden and my own
country finland
on second march the general assembly by
an overwhelming majority deplored in the
strongest terms the aggression by the
russian federation against ukraine in
violation of the charter
russia's aggression is not only illegal
and unprovoked we also see shocking
reports of atrocity crimes including
allegations of sexual violence which are
all acts
unequivocally prohibited under
international law
there cannot be impunity for the most
serious international crimes
all perpetrators must be brought to
justice this is necessary to ensure
justice for victims but also to deter
future violations
the nordic countries were among those
state parties that referred the
situation in ukraine to the
international criminal court
the icc plays a central role in our
collective response at the international
level
we welcome the fast mobilization of the
icc prosecutor in the situation of
ukraine
echoing the icc prosecutor the only
agenda is the truth
the
icc however is a court of last resort
insofar as possible the most serious
crimes under international law should be
investigated and prosecuted in national
jurisdictions
ukraine despite being a nation under
attack has made a tremendous effort to
document the most serious international
crimes on its territory we must support
ukraine in these efforts
a number of countries have also
initiated criminal investigations under
universal jurisdiction complementing the
efforts undertaken in ukraine nationally
and the icc internationally
many civil society organizations are
also working to document and collect
evidence
coordination and cooperation will remain
key in order to ensure effective
investigations
madam president in addition to
individual criminal responsibility
we must also bear in mind that every
internationally wrongful act of a state
entails the international responsibility
of that state
we must invoke russia's responsibility
for the violations of international
humanitarian law and human rights law
this is being advanced by various
mechanisms including under the human
human human rights council and the osce
we also remind the security council of
its power and duty to decisively respond
to threats to international peace and
security we strongly encourage the
council to remain ceased of the
situation in ukraine
also in order to advance accountability
ensuring accountability is an integral
part of our obligation to respect and
ensure compliance for human rights and
international human rights law
central instruments of human rights and
international humanitarian law were
drafted over 70 years ago and are
customary international law and
standards the obligation to protect
civilians is as important as ever
ensuring accountability is also key to
bringing about durable peace future
peace requires action now i thank you
madam chair
i thank the representative of finland
and would like to give the floor to the
minister of foreign affairs of the
netherlands for a pre-recorded statement
bullet holes can be filled in
walls can be rebuilt
and roofs can be repaired
but some damage
cannot be fixed
the physical and mental trauma caused by
sexual violence
trauma that women
and sometimes men
carry with them
for the rest
of their lives
there is growing evidence that russian
troops have been using sexual violence
as a weapon of war
and the gruesome testimonies
of girls and women are hard to bear
and go beyond
our comprehension
this violence was not aimed at military
targets
its only purpose
its only purpose was to destroy people's
souls violence
against humanity itself
these crimes
must not go unpunished
and that is why i am grateful to albania
france ukraine for organizing this
important event
and that is why we call on the icc to
bring to justice
those who have committed these atrocious
crimes
not only because we owe it to the
victims but because impunity leads to
more violence
and to more impunity
and to yet
more violence
and we cannot allow that
justice must be done we all agree on
this
we've all said it
and we all know that getting there is
much harder than just saying it
because getting there means doing more
and we must do more
to protect women and girls
more to ensure that justice
actually works
by strengthening the mechanisms
that leads to prosecution
by professionalizing the rules and
standards for evidence gathering
and by raising awareness that evidence
must meet a certain standard of proof
in ukraine the destructive power of
violence is being countered by the power
of courageous people
of the countless ngos and citizen groups
who are collecting and sharing videos
photos and other
of the citizens who are riding to my
ministry with evidence
their combined strength is driven by
justice
and it must lead
to justice
the international community has an
important role to play here
together we must ensure that the road to
accountability and peace is a durable
one
that justice
is not only our desired endpoints
but that we actually get there
because justice is a journey
not just a destination
thank you very much
i thank foreign minister holstra for his
statement and i give the floor to the
minister of foreign affairs of romania
for a pre-recorded statement
mrs president distinguished colleagues
romania welcomes the initiative of
albania and france in cooperation with
ukraine
to hold a meeting in the area formula on
the topic of ensuring accountability for
atrocities committed in ukraine
romania took every opportunity to
strongly condemn the brutal unjustified
and unprovoked illegal military
aggression directed by moscow against
ukraine
the humanitarian situation continues to
deteriorate
the conflict has caused the world's
fastest growing displacement crisis
since the second world war
more than
828 000 ukrainian refugees have crossed
the romanian ukrainian border
on the ground the traces of indisputable
aggression against civilians speak
louder than any words
i have just returned from ukraine today
where i have visited together with the
romanian prime minister and the romanian
speaker of the chamber of deputies the
cities of europe and borodianca
i am personally still very much affected
by what i saw on the ground
we are horrified by the reported war
crimes
crimes of genocide and crimes against
humanity
committed in ukraine and we call once
more on the russian federation
to stop its unlawful and unacceptable
behavior towards the civilian population
no perpetrator of the atrocities in
ukraine shall remain unpunished
it gives us real hope to see an
unprecedented unified response on behalf
of the international community
in support of holding accountable all
those involved in blatant violations of
international law
including international humanitarian law
and human rights
romania has therefore joined other
states parties to the rome statute
in a referral to the prosecutor of the
international criminal court
to investigate any acts of war crimes
crimes against humanity and genocide
that have occurred on the territory of
ukraine
in addition the romanian government has
recently approved a voluntary financial
contribution of 100 000 euro in response
to the icc prosecutor's appeal to
state's parties we stand ready to
support
further the efforts of the of the office
with adequate resources
against the background of increased
workloads including the new
investigation
on the territory of ukraine
romania places its full trust in the
independent and impartial ability of the
icc
to bring justice in ukraine and all the
other situations under its consideration
we will continue to support its vital
role in the fight against impunity and
in providing assistance and reparations
to victims of mass atrocities
romania also welcomed the order of the
international court of justice of march
16
calling on the russian federation to
immediately suspend military operations
in the territory of ukraine
we urge full and unequivocal compliance
with this order
furthermore romania will continue to
promote its declaration calling for a
broader recognition of the icj's
jurisdiction and we encourage all states
to join us in our demarch
we will not stop here romania supports
targeted efforts to investigate human
rights and international humanitarian
law violations
such as the establishment of the
independent international commission of
inquiry on ukraine and the invocation of
the moscow mechanism of the osce
in addition romania became a member of
the group of friends of accountability
following the aggression against ukraine
the international community must
continue to stand firm against russia's
unacceptable aggression
and to stand united in protecting those
who are already suffering or facing
imminent threats
we must continue to condemn and publicly
expose the attacks against civilians and
civilian facilities in ukraine
in addition it is our duty to address
russian war propaganda and this
information more effectively
to never turn a blind eye on attempts to
re-electivize the truth of sufferance
we should continue to appropriately
respond to ukraine's needs and to the
specific requests of all international
bodies and mechanisms
that we have set up with the aim of
contributing to more accountability as
regards the situation in ukraine
our commitment has to be consistent and
long-standing
fatigue is not acceptable in the pursuit
of justice
we should also ensure that the existing
mechanisms and platforms for
accountability do not overlap
and do not create gaps in investigation
the activity of the group of friends on
accountability following the aggression
against ukraine could be particularly
useful to this effect
finally we have to help the victims with
compassion and dignity
romania has been at the forefront of
this effort as one of the countries
receiving
very large numbers of ukrainians fleeing
the terror since the beginning of the
war
romania is committed to continue helping
the population in need be it on the
territory of ukraine or as beneficiaries
of international protection on our
territory thank you for your attention
i thank foreign minister aresko for his
statement and i'd like to give the floor
to deputy foreign minister of lithuania
for a pre-recorded statement
excellencies we are grateful to the
permanent missions
of albania and france for convening this
area formula meeting in cooperation with
ukraine
and thank the panel of remarkable
briefers for their inspiring
contributions to this discussion
lithuania aligns itself with the
statement of the united nations group of
friends of accountability following the
aggression against ukraine we will
continuously contribute to the
activities of the group both here in new
york and in geneva
at the birth of the united nations in
the aftermath of the second world war it
was said never again
unfortunately after numerous bloody
conflicts of the past several decades
a war is once again unleashed on the
continent of europe with an extreme
brutality and devastation brought forth
by russia all across ukraine
as we enter into the third month of this
war
reports by the united nations officials
civil society and journalists speak of
gross and revolting violations of
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law
the images of mass graves bodies on the
streets burned beyond recognition and
evidence of sexual and gender-based
violence including rape targeted
killings torture arbitrary arrests
abductions enforced disappearances
use of cluster munitions in residential
areas as well as mass deportations of
civilians into the russian territory
contribute to the mounting statistics of
death and devastation
we also mourn the international
journalists and media workers killed by
russian troops
they tell a heart-rending yet
unfortunately still ongoing story
this war has far-reaching consequences
for many regions in the world
beginning from threats to nuclear safety
and fears of use of chemical weapons to
already felt hardships to food security
as underlined by the united nations
secretary general those directly
responsible for war crimes and crimes
against humanity violations of human
rights and international humanitarian
law on ukrainian soil must be held
accountable
there will be no impunity
there will be accountability for this
horror and international justice will be
done
victims will have access to remedy and
to justice
lithuania condemns in the strongest
possible terms russia's war against
ukraine
and will continue to steadfastly support
all efforts to ensure independent and
effective investigations into crimes
committed by russia in ukraine
russia and its accomplice belarus bear
full responsibility for this large-scale
unprovoked unlawful and unjustified war
of aggression
we recall that russia must comply with
the 16th of march binding order of the
international court of justice and
immediately suspend the military
operations in the whole internationally
recognized territory of ukraine
lithuania actively supported and voted
for the establishment of the commission
of inquiry by the united nations human
rights council
it will be up to us the un member states
to ensure its adequate funding as well
as to encourage this practical
cooperation with the un's special
procedures and mandate holders
we welcome the work conducted under the
osce moscow mechanism
it is now upon the osce participating
states and the international community
to ensure the follow-up actions to be
undertaken
lithuania as the first member state to
refer the situation in ukraine to the
prosecutor of the international criminal
court will continue to support the
office of the prosecutor in its
investigation concerning alleged war
crimes and crimes against humanity
committed in ukraine
fact-finding and evidence-gathering
forms the cornerstone to fighting
impunity
we maintain that cooperation within the
national investigators based on
universal jurisdiction is enhancing the
documenting and mapping of the crimes
committed and identifying those
responsible
we suggest that the good practices of
cooperation can serve as an impactful
source of assistance to the prosecutor
of the international criminal court as
the icc does not possess independent
enforcement powers and relies on the
member states for their support
the national authorities need
coordination of investigation actions
share the information and workload avoid
repetitive actions allocate resources
transfer data and evidence between each
other and to the international criminal
court prosecutor
we need to use common approach on the
procedures of evidence collection to
ensure their admissibility and
reliability
a coordinated work with an involvement
of civil society
journalists media workers and ngos is
essential
at the initiative of lithuania the joint
investigation team into allegations of
international crimes committed in
ukraine was created in eurojust in march
it comprises ukrainian polish and
lithuanian representatives
the team will support the gathering of
evidence as well as its swift and secure
exchange
we highly welcome the decision of the
prosecutor of the international criminal
court to join the joint investigation
team
we invite the member states that started
national investigations based on
universal jurisdiction to consider
joining it
we will double down on our efforts of
investigating all further legal avenues
minister of justice of lithuania will
host an international conference on the
6th of may that will be that will be
dedicated to discussion of all legal
mechanisms that could ensure
accountability of putin's and
lukashenko's regimes for the crime of
aggression
we the international community must seek
full accountability for the atrocities
committed in ukraine
in order for us to honorably follow our
words with deeds we must continue to
defend the charter
the international law human rights peace
and security and our own humanity itself
i thank you
i thank deputy minister adomenas for his
statement and the last pre-recorded
statement is from the state secretary of
montenegro
madame chairperson i would like to begin
by thanking you for convening today's
every meeting on this exceedingly
critical issue
i also take the opportunity to thank
today's briefers
for their valuable inputs to this debate
montenegro aligns itself with the
statement made by danish foreign
minister on behalf of the group of
friends
of accountability following the
aggression against ukraine but i would
nonetheless like to accentuate certain
points of importance to us
we are deeply troubled and unsettled by
the widespread images and reports of
indiscriminate killings of civilians
including the most vulnerable ones
as well as the attacks on civilian
infrastructure
by the russian federation
the execution of innocent and unarmed
civilians in bucha and the shelling of
the cremators railway station is not
only a war crime it constitutes a defeat
of civilization values and the
rules-based international order
principles at the very heart of the
aggression of ukraine and the very ones
we fought to achieve
and preserve throughout the years
such onslaught represent a blatant and
auditious violation of international
humanitarian law
and international human rights law for
which we seek and demand accountability
montenegro welcomes
the ongoing investigation of the
international criminal courts prosecutor
in ukraine reiterates its support for
engagement of the un commission of
inquire on ukraine
especially ohchr
and the civil society organizations
actions undertaken by these actors
are indispensable in terms of collecting
crucial evidence
of the ramification of the russian
opera's unprecedented aggression
we call on the international community
to vocally and continually express its
condemnation and denunciation of this
unprovoked act of warm ongoing attacks
on civilians and critical infrastructure
human rights violation and infringement
of humanitarian law
madam chairperson
we must have accountability
if we are to end impunity and give peace
and reconciliation a chance
the victory against impunity
is not something achieved overnight and
without breaking as well
still
i propose that it can be accomplished if
pursued with determination and a united
stand stands against the perpetrator
montenegro stands ready
to do it
to do its part
thank you very much
i thank state secretary misurovic for
his statement
and before we continue uh seeing how we
are past uh the limit of time that we
had allocated for this meeting
and
seeing how there was not much that we
could do with the pre-recorded
statements i would like to kindly ask
the participants in the room to limit
their statements to one minute if
possible and i also encourage speakers
to deposit their statements with our
team in case they choose not to speak
but
i'm asking for your understanding
because we have to
conclude by 6 30.
and
having said that i would like to give
the floor to the representative of italy
uh ambassador you have the floor
thank you uh madam chair uh the
unjustified military regression rush
against ukraine
is shaking the fundamental pillars of
the rules-based international order
italy is the view that accountability is
key to making sure that
these pillars now shaken will not be
irreversibly damaged to this end
server's roots must be followed i will
mention shortly four of these rules
first we must make sure that those
responsible for war crimes and crimes
against humanity in ukraine are brought
to justice before competent domestic
courts and if needed before the
international criminal court
second we emphasize that aggression is
in itself an international crime
entailing the
individual responsibility of those
orchestrating the military attack
against a sovereign country
last year italy gratified the kampala
amendment to the roman statute
activating the jurisdiction of the court
over the crime of aggression we call on
all states parties to follow suit and
non-state parties to ratify the wrong
the kampala amendment third italy fully
supports ukraine legal action against
the russian federation before the
international court of justice the
russian federation is bound under
international law to comply with the
judgments and decisions of the icj
including the order of
16 march this year to immediately
suspend its military operations in
ukraine last the first point italy also
supports the collection of evidence by
both the osce moscow mechanism and the
independent commission of inquire
established by human rights council as
well as the work of the un human rights
monitoring mission in ukraine i thank
you
thank you ambassador and i would like to
give the floor to the representative of
latvia
against ukraine facilitated by belarus
require accountability for the grave
violations of international human rights
law international humanitarian law
and every legal avenue available must
and will be used to hold the aggressor
to account
latvia has engaged in several
accountability mechanisms to address the
mass atrocities being committed in
ukraine notably latvia has taken the
decision to participate as a third party
in the case related to allegation of
genocide brought by ukraine against
russia before international court of
justice and latvia is one of 43 state
parties to the international criminal
court that have referred to situation in
ukraine to the prosecutor of icc
enabling the prosecutor to proceed with
investigations into allegations of war
crimes crimes against humanity or
genocide committed on any party of the
territory of ukraine by any person we
have also nominated national experts and
provided volunteer contributions of 100
000 euros to the icc and addressing the
challenges the icc is facing in the
conduct of these and other
investigations we particularly welcome
the decision of the office of prosecutor
to join the joint investigation team on
international crimes committed in
ukraine last but not least in exercising
the universal jurisdiction the state
security service of latvia has launched
criminal proceedings for war crimes and
crimes against humanity and peace
committed by russian armed forces in
ukraine to obtain and document evidence
we likewise welcome the establishment of
international commission of inquirer in
ukraine to investigate all alleged
violations and abuses of human rights
and violations of international criminal
humanitarian law the last fourth thought
why russia's economy is plummeting due
to the most severe sanctions in history
being imposed on russia because of its
war against ukraine and atrocities
against its people it seems that the
main export good of russia continues to
be the human rights violations
we have to stop that expert like we
have to stop expert of russia's coal oil
and gas i thank you madam chair
i think the representative of latvian
would like to give the floor to the
representative of estonia
thank you madam chair
we thank albania france and ukraine for
convening today's aria meeting that
estonia is honored to co-sponsor
estonia aligns itself with the
statements by the european union and the
accountability group of friends
but i'm sure
it has been over two months since nazi
russia started the unprovoked absolutely
illegitimate full-scale war on ukraine
russian forces are committing
unspeakable barbarities against ukraine
and the ukrainians that have been
rightfully prohibited under
international law because they are
inhumane
estonia has always been a strong
supporter of the international criminal
court that forms an important pillar of
the rules-based international order and
we welcome the investigation by the icc
in ukraine
estonia has also started a domestic
structural investigation into war crimes
and crimes against humanity committed in
ukraine and is cooperating with eurojust
in this regard
we continue to call on russia to abide
by the order of the international court
of justice for russia to immediately
suspend the military operations that it
commenced on 24th of february on the
territory of ukraine
it is crucial that evidence of war
crimes
committed in ukraine continues to be
gathered in a manner that will
hold up in independent impartial
judicial institutions all of the
information collected needs to be made
available to the relevant accountability
mechanisms and courts accountability
mechanisms need to cooperate and
complement each other's mandates
the destabilizing effects of russia's
aggression are felt throughout the world
the the only country that needs to stop
the senseless war is this in is the
instigator
the russian federation
the individuals perpetrating atrocities
will need to stop executing unlawful
orders or face the consequences the
world is watching and is united in
horror with that we stand with ukraine
we mourn
every life lost due to senseless russian
aggression we need to do more to save
ukrainian lives already now while we
work hard for justice to be done thank
you madam chair
i thank the representative of estonia
and give the floor to the representative
of germany
thank you madam minister
i will make my full statement available
but let me make three points which are
important to me today
the first is despite
the
numerous russian attempts to spread
disinformation
including in this meeting and at all
levels
in an equalized manner
it is clear that we have ongoing and
everyday fresh reports about crimes
committed by the russian forces
and
related groups or organizations
and it is very important that we go into
this issue and
collect
evidence to make
the perpetrators accountable
my second point is that we of course
in this context think that the
investigations by the international
criminal court
prosecutor are extremely important and
we will have provided and will provide
additional
means and personnel financial means and
personnel to carry on with this
and of course we have also foreseen
additional funding for the mission of
the high commissioner for human rights
in ukraine
and my last point to be short germany
will remain firmly committed to
supporting all efforts in the
in the context of accountability
everywhere
in the world on the globe and we owe it
to the victims of these atrocious crimes
and to their families thank you
i thank you ambassador and would like uh
to give the floor to the representative
of croatia
thank you madam chair i will reduce my
intervention to only a couple of
questions and a simpler and clear answer
if there were accountability for
aggression and annexation of crimea in
2014 and crimes committed in donbass
from 2014 onwards would there be a new
wave of aggression and atrocity crimes
committed starting from february 24 this
year
how many lives and human misery could
have been spared
what will be the consequences if there
is no accountability this time yet again
will in couple of years kiev be
wiped of the face of earth as this time
mariupolis would some other european or
non-european capital be wiped out as
well
distinguished colleagues it is my firm
belief that if there is no
accountability for atrocity crimes
committed in ukraine atrocities will
never end they can only worsen we need
accountability and we need to fight for
it now it brings justice for victims as
well as prevents future atrocities it is
going to be a long and challenging way
but as doug hammershield once said
future is the horizon but also the first
step that we will take tomorrow thank
you
thank you ambassador and i would like to
give the floor to the representative of
poland
madam chair uh also for the sake of the
debate i will provide the full statement
in writing i just want to say a few
sentences
on behalf of poland firstly we do
believe that the only way to prevent the
further suffering is to fully implement
the resolution entitled aggression
against ukraine and we believe that all
bodies of the u.n system should treat
its provisions as a guidance and
obligation this is the voice of the
international community expressly
presented in the in this resolution
secondly uh while as you all know
most of poland's activities are now
focused on the humanitarian aid related
to hosting the largest number of
refugees in history
on polish soil uh we as a poland we are
also taking steps to bring the
perpetrators to justice acting on
international and also on the national
level
in that
regard firstly i would i want to say
also that uh as the osce chairmanship in
office poland decided to hold
discussions and considerations on the
organization including the regular human
dimension events as a relevant and
useful response to the atrocities
committed in ukraine
also as an oec chairmanship we welcome
the report joined by the osce moscow
mechanism experts professors of gang
benedict veronica bilkova and marcos
asoli
being at the same time extremely
concerned by the appalling reality that
it describes
the document conference patterns of
violation of international humanitarian
law and human rights law committed by
the russian federation during the
aggression against ukraine
then of course we express satisfaction
uh with the u.n human rights council
established a dedicated commission of
inquiry whose experts have been already
appointed and we heard them today and we
fully support their work and look
forward for its outcome
then of course at domestic level polish
national prosecutor's office opened an
investigation into russia's crime of war
of aggression against ukraine which is
penalized under the polish law together
with ukraine lithuania we established
the joint investigation team which
operates within the framework of euro
just in order to collect and preserve
evidence of crimes committed to ukraine
and of course we decided also to respond
positively to an invitation extended by
the icc prosecutor to provide assistance
to the office including through the
provision of national experts on a
secondment basis and the voluntary
contributions in order to address office
uh urgent needs
as far as the state responsibilities
concerned we welcomed the decision of
the icj issued on the 16 march on
provisional measures in the case of
ukraine versus russia concerning the
allegations of the genocide under the
convention of the prevention of
punishment of the crime of genocide
provision measures are legally binding
therefore russia's failure to comply
with them bluntly shows their disrespect
for the law and additional institutions
and just let me finish by by expressing
as our german colleague said we fully
support all the efforts for
accountability
uh also all the efforts for
accountability against the lies that we
also uh it's more than misinformation
this lies that we also heard today in
this room and i thank you very much
thank you ambassador and i also thank
you uh for
your understanding of cooperation and
submitting a full
uh statement uh in writing
i would like now to give the floor to
the representative of
belgium
belgium fully aligns itself with the
statement delivered by the european
union and by the group of friends on
accountability
and we wish to make three additional
remarks first
since russia russia's unjustified an
unprovoked aggression against ukraine in
february
reports of attacks on civilians
including children have been growing
there have been numerous reports of
conflict-related gender-based violence
we strongly call for the respect of the
rule of law international humanitarian
law and international human rights law
by all parties involved in the conflict
and we further reaffirm our solidarity
with ukraine and with the ukrainian
people
secondly madam minister my country
considers it necessary to conduct
investigations and to gather evidence
which will allow justice to be served
my delegation comments the efforts
undertaken by the prosecutor general of
ukraine to investigate these facts
and belgium also welcomes the
cooperation within the framework of
coordination organized by eurogis
in which our belgian federal
prosecutor's office is actively
participating the findings are clear the
osce report mentions confirmed cases of
violations of international humanitarian
law we further look forward to the
results of the commissions of inquiry
established by the human rights council
and i would like you to add that it is
vital that that commission receives the
funding it needs to function properly
belgium is one of the 41 states that
referred the situation in ukraine to the
international criminal court last march
in this regard belgium has just
announced a contribution of 500 000
euros to the trust fund created by the
office of the prosecutor to enable it to
cope with a significant increase in its
workload
it is important to coordinate the
various efforts underway to ensure that
current initiatives are mutually
reinforcing and meet sufficiently high
standards
so that the evidence collected can
actually be used in criminal procedures
finally we are particularly concerned
about the situation pertaining to
children
children are amongst the most vulnerable
victims of armed conflicts hundreds of
schools and educational facilities have
been subjected to indiscriminate attacks
and too many children have died
we must ensure that the perpetrators of
those crimes are held accountable
unfortunately children are still not
given their rightful place in judicial
proceedings belgium therefore calls for
children to be systematically recognized
as a full category of victims before
national hybrid and international courts
as well as before transitional justice
mechanisms and to conclude my minister
madam chair belgium will remain
committed to accountability for the most
serious crimes under international law
in all situations and therefore also in
ukraine in the immediate future a
cessation of facilities is essential in
order to prevent more civilians from
becoming victims of this senseless war i
thank you for your attention thank you
ambassador and i would like to give the
floor to the representative of
luxembourg
thank you very much
madam chair luxembourg
is proud to have co-sponsored this area
formula meeting
organized by albania and france in
cooperation with ukraine with a strong
focus on ensuring accountability for the
atrocities committed in ukraine
the reports that we receive show that
indeed atrocities are being committed
by
the russian armed forces in ukraine
including rape and other forms of sexual
violence targeting in particular women
and children
we must do everything possible to hold
the perpetrators accountable and to
bring justice to the victims who must be
at the center of our efforts
the important documentation work on the
way is crucial in this regard and we
salute the courage and resilience of the
prosecutor general of ukraine and her
teams working relentlessly to document
violations as they occur
luxembourg supported the establishment
by the human rights council of the
commission of inquiry and we were glad
to hear today that the commission is
about to start its work
we were also among the many states
that have referred the situation in
ukraine to the prosecutor of the
international criminal court and we
thank prosecutor khan for his very clear
statement today
luxembourg has just announced a
voluntary contribution of 100 000 euros
to the icc it remains essential to
provide the court with the necessary
resources
to fulfill its important mandate in
ukraine as well as in all other
situations
in conclusion luxembourg remains
committed to standing by the people of
ukraine
its partners and the international
judicial bodies to prevent impunity
and ensure effective and impartial
justice
for the atrocities that are being
committed in ukraine i thank you
thank you ambassador and i would also
like to thank the representative of
litenstein the czech republic
and slovakia
and switzerland as well for submitting
their statements in writing i would like
to give the floor to the representative
of australia
thank you indeed minister and this is a
sadly necessary meeting which australia
is pleased to co-sponsor as a member of
the accountability group of friends and
the briefers have given us insights into
the complexities and challenges in
holding perpetrators to account
but we must persevere
in australia uh yet again
condemns the russian federation's
unprovoked
unjust and illegal invasion of ukraine
and we yet again call on russia to
immediately withdraw its forces
consistent with the legally binding
decision of the international court of
justice
minister
russia has committed egregious war
crimes across ukraine and we're all
appalled by the horrific acts torture
mass executions rape shelling civilians
forced deportations of adults forced
deportations of children starving cities
through siege
the list of atrocities grows daily
it's imperative that we ensure
accountability for the crimes committed
in ukraine and that's why australia
joined over 80 uh sorry over 40 rome
statute states parties to refer the
situation in ukraine to the
international criminal court
and australia strongly supports
prosecutor khan opening an investigation
and we're pleased to support his office
at this exceptionally challenging time
including through our decision to send
professional staff to assist with his
work
and australia has joined global partners
in imposing far-reaching sanctions to
inflict heavy costs on those responsible
all those who hold labors of power
chair uh the international community
stands in solidarity with ukraine
russia's violations of international law
will not be met with impunity thank you
i thank you ambassador and i would also
like to thank the representative of
canada and the republic of korea for
submitting their statements in writing
i would like to give the floor to the
representative of malta
thank you madam president in the
interest of time i will just refer to
the saving point of my statement which
will submit in full in writing i thank
albania and france
for this meeting as members of the group
of friends on accountability in ukraine
will welcome today's discussion
malta aligns himself with a statement by
the european union and would like to
deliver this few salient points in our
national capacity madam president the
indiscriminate shelling of civilian
infrastructure and the bombing of
schools and hospitals is completely
unacceptable under violation of
international humanitarian law or
reports of atrocities war crimes must be
investigated accountability goes beyond
the judicial process and the security
council and the general assembly have
crucial roles to play
the report delivered by the osce moscow
mechanism underlining the clear pattern
of humanitarian and human rights
violations is of grave concern and
another pillar in the accountability
mechanisms which are available to member
states malta joins the unprecedented
referral to the icc to investigate what
is happening in ukraine and welcomes a
rapid action taken by the prosecutor to
open an investigation we believe this is
work of vital importance for the
international community also the
establishment of a commission of inquiry
by the human rights council
was another important step madam
president has a direct result of the
unjustified and unprovoked aggression by
russia against ukraine neighboring
countries have also had to step up to
offer shelter aid and assistance to
millions of ukrainians who have been
fleeing their homes this is the biggest
refugee crisis in europe since what the
second world war we extend our
appreciation to them as well as to
several u.n agencies who have been
working on the ground to offer
assistance to the millions of internally
displaced persons in ukraine finally
madam president to ensure accountability
it is important that the right steps are
taken
from the very beginning we urge the u.n
security council to fulfill its mandate
in preserving peace and security and ask
all member states to ensure that
accountability remains on the un agenda
being an effective means in upholding
international law thank you
i thank you ambassador and i would like
to remind you that at this moment we
still have four speakers and some five
minutes of time left so i'm sure you
will help me to conclude in time i would
like to give the floor to the
representative of bulgaria
hoping for your understanding and
cooperation of course thank you
thank you madam chair bulgaria alliances
itself with the statement made on behalf
of the european union on behalf of the
group of friends of accountability i
would like to thank you for organizing
this area meeting on a topic of extreme
importance which should remain high on
the agenda i would also like to thank
the briefers for their very sobering
interventions since the early morning of
24th of february when the russian
federation initiated the
and provoked and unjustified military
aggression against ukraine
in complete violation of international
law and the principles of the u.n
torture the lives of millions of
ukrainians have been literally destroyed
there have been daily reports of
numerous civilian casualties as a
and of attacks of schools hospitals
residential buildings and civilian
objects which all constitute gross
violations of international humanitarian
law and human rights law words failed to
describe the images that emerged from
bhuta according to human rights watch
conflict researcher nearly every coroner
in bucha is now a crime scene and it
felt like that was everywhere there is a
growing number of reports in sexual and
gender-based violence being used as a
tactic of war the situation of children
is particularly worrisome those crimes
cannot and should not be left without
consequences the perpetrators will be
held accountable the international
community has to stand united to ensure
that justice is served impunity is not
an option investigations have already
been undertaken by the icc prosecutor as
well as
at national level in several countries
we need to unite forces to assist the
office of the prosecutor general of
ukraine and law enforcement agencies is
that we can make sure that all evidence
is properly collected and testimonies
are well documented so that no crimes
goes unpunished it is of equal
importance though to keep the issue high
on the political agenda in all possible
fora the international community has to
make it explicitly clear that there is
no room for impunity for the crimes in
ukraine or elsewhere
only through ensuring that justice is
served can we prevent such atrocities
from happening again we owe it to the
victims but most of all we owe it to
ourselves thank you
thank you ambassador and i would like to
give the floor to the representative of
georgia
thank you madam chair
for the
interest of time we'll submit our full
statement in writing
uh let me
reiterate that georgia fully aligns
itself with the statement made on behalf
of the group of friends of
accountability and i would like to
highlight few points it is imperative
that accountability is ensured for the
gross violations
of international law including
international humanitarian law and human
rights law committed by russia we must
avail of all relevant international
legal mechanisms to ensure that justice
is served for the crimes that russia is
committing in this regard as a
co-sponsor of the respective hrc
resolution georgia welcomes the
establishment of an independent
international commission of inquiry to
investigate all alleged violations and
abuses of human rights and violations of
international law
and related crimes in the context of the
human in of the russian federation's
aggression against ukraine
georgia strongly supports the work of
icc and was among the states referring
the situation in ukraine to the court we
welcome the announcement of the icc
prosecutor to immediately proceed with
an active investigation and look forward
to further progress
i would like to reiterate our call on
russia to comply with the provisional
measures of the international court of
justice of march 16 to immediately stop
aggression withdraw all its forces from
the whole territory of ukraine allow
immediate safe and unfettered access of
all international humanitarian and human
rights mechanisms finally we reiterate
george's unwavering support to ukraine's
independence sovereignty and territorial
integrity within its internationally
recognized borders including crimea and
donbass as well as for ukraine's
navigational rights in its territorial
waters i thank you i thank the
representative of georgia and give the
floor to the representative of japan
thank you madame
first of all allow me to express on
behalf of the government japan our sense
of solidarity with the people of ukraine
japan as co-hosting country of this
meeting vehemently condemns the killings
of civilians in attacks on civilian
infrastructure by russia the mass
killing of innocent civilians including
children women journalists and medical
and humanitarian personnel is a grave
breach of international humanitarian law
and constitutes war crimes
perpetrators of such acts must be
identified and held accountable japan
has referred the situation in ukraine to
the international criminal code and we
look forward to continued progress in
the investigation by prosecutor current
we would like to continue to contribute
to the icc's activities while
maintaining close conduct with the icc
and its state parties
sustaining peace will never be achieved
without tackling impunity japan will
continue to work together with our
partner to this end thank you
i thank the representative of japan and
give the floor to the representative of
chile
okay the representative of chile is not
here they will be submitting their
statement in writing and with that i'd
like to thank all our briefers and
member states for their participation
and contribution we feel very encouraged
by the level of interest and
engagement on a matter of crucial
importance such as assuring
accountability for atrocities committed
in ukraine the legal threshold for
providing war crimes and crimes against
humanity is high as
most of you here said and the system has
in the past proved torturous in its
proceedings and slow to deliver justice
but ukraine and russia are still at war
and to really respond to the scale of
russia's attack we have to connect what
is happening today to the violations
from the past to show how they have a
way of repeating over and over again we
have to tell not just the stories of
people hurt and and killed in this war
but also the history culture and the way
of life putin is trying to wipe out
our aim is one only to ensure justice
both in normal courts and in the court
of public opinion which is a key
ingredient to keep us alert and to
mobilize political action to support
justice everywhere in thanking you once
again for your active participation this
meeting is adjourned